good afternoon council please be seated
good afternoon
everybody i'm very aware that you've got
a full agenda
including uh budget setting so it won't
be too long i'm afraid i'm not going to
hang around for the budget setting i've
got it's going to be four hours or
something so uh enjoy
um
but um
i'm aware as well that we have a focus
on our local communities but i wondered
perhaps whether our prayers today could
have a focus beyond that
um beyond our shores even
um
maybe we could take a short moment to
focus
on eastern europe
and what appears to be an escalating
situation between russia and ukraine and
as we all know western governments are
suggesting that an invasion is to be
expected
and we've all seen pictures of the
180 190 000 troops that seem to have
amassed
on the ukraine borders
and i'm sure you're aware as well that
it's the normal person
on both sides
uh that is going to be most impacted if
something does happen
in ukraine of course um since russia
invaded the crimea um there's been
effectively a war going
on and in russia
um
surely this would spell economic
disaster in a former life
i spent many years out in russia working
for a charity that supported or needed
children out there
and when i think of russia it's their
faces
that come to mind
if honest i cannot really imagine how
life get could get worse
for those
young people but that was 15 years ago
and it's already got worse due to
economic sanctions
so what the cost of a major war would
bring to normal people in russia it
doesn't really bear thinking about
so i find myself asking the question
where is the hope
or is there any
and in thinking about this when i ask
that question
a verse a line even from matthew's
gospel
came to mind
blessed are the peacemakers
for they will be called children of god
now you will know
you will know the peacemakers in your
community
in your families and in your places of
work you may even be a peacemaker
yourself
peacemakers are people who have a
natural gift of bringing peace in
conflict
maybe in your role as a counselor you
feel like you're often
a peacemaker
i certainly know of many clergy that
would feel
like that in their roles
but it is the peacemakers that i think
we should be praying for as we look
at this out at this rising tension
both the professional peacemaker
those working at a diplomatic level
negotiating arranging meetings between
leaders
and those natural peacemakers living in
their communities on both sides of the
border
working to suppress hatred of the other
working to calm the storms in people's
lives
and hearts
i sometimes think the peacemakers in
society get a bit overlooked
but the outcome of their work can bring
joy hope relief restoration
healing
love even
these are things we associate with the
character and ministry of jesus
hence blessed
are the peacemakers for they will be
called children of god
will they be successful
we don't know
but i believe it will be through them
that god will bring his peace if they
are so
i hope so as i'm sure
you hope so too
so let us pray
almighty god we pray for the situation
on the border of ukraine
lord we ask that you raise up
peacemakers on all sides
that war and violence may be averted
give diplomats wisdom understanding
and build trust
we pray that the voices for discernment
and peaceful solutions may prosper
we lift
be
successful we also pray for those who
live in fear and uncertainty
that you may grant them your peace
and comfort at this time
we ask for the church in the nations
involved may they be salt and light in
their communities at this dark time
father we lift this dangerous situation
to you
may your kingdom come
may your peace reign amen
thank you i hope you have a good meeting
great thank you and i forgot to use my
hammer so let's use it now to formally
open amazing there we go um
so i'd like to invite the
head of paid services to report the list
of apologies of absence please
thank you chairman we have can you hear
me
can you hear me yeah okay thank you um
apologies have been received from
councillors cleve
parry
richards and rolf and we are expecting
councillor o'donnell but probably a
little bit late thank you
oh and peter hancher serif in pardon me
thank you
thank you um now i'd like to invite any
members to make their declarations of
interest at the museum council shenzhen
thank you chair i'd like to declare an
interesting item six
so
when that comes up i will
leave them at the chamber
thank you counselor
great
thank you um so moving on to iceland
three the minutes let's now seek a
proposal and second for the minutes of
the meeting held on the 13th of december
i'll find a proposal please
councillor mills and the seconder
council dixon
lovely thank you
um so
a quick announcement from myself is um
on friday 25th of march we've got the
chairman's ball and bingo and thank you
to so many of you who have bought
tickets for that's much much appreciated
um so that's something i'm really
looking forward to and thanks to claire
johnson for helping to organize which
can be quite a special event
um
so now i'd like to invite the leader of
the council uh councillor jefferson to
speak
thank you chair
um
three things to announce
first i had a meeting with stuart croft
vice chancellor of the university
warwick martin yardley and andrew day
regarding the wells born campus
second at a meeting with
managers from lotus cars
concerning their expansion strategy
and third
did a presentation to andy street mayor
of the west midlands on the projects
currently underway in stratford-on-haven
thank you and um
the chief executive please
thank you chairman no announcements but
i just wanted to make a comment in
relation to the additional papers that
you got in front of you today you do
have a lot of additional papers and i
just want to make sure that you're aware
which items the papers relate to so
you'll have
in a paperclip items from the cabinet
and they relate to items 6 8 9
and 10
on the agenda
you've then got
a bright yellow
sheet which is the
amendment coming forward from the lib
dem group in relation to the budget
i'm actually my shirt you then have on
the move
colored paper
an additional item for item 11 in
relation to the actual council tax
resolution so that couldn't have been
circulated earlier the pcc just resolved
on on his budget yesterday
you've then got two separate pink items
one for item 13 and one from item 14
from the audit and standards committee
one in relation to the lga code and one
in relation to the calendar of meetings
and then a slightly
off
less bright yellow a buff maybe one
could call it um from the employment and
appointment committee that's for
covering items 15
and 16.
and then finally as his tradition the
questions to council that's on a
fetching green color this afternoon i
just want to make sure you've got those
additional papers there are quite a lot
apologies have been a number of meetings
which are held are very approximate to
the meeting the council and we couldn't
have got them onto the agenda proper
thank you chairman
leader
yep council jefferson
great thank you um i'd now like to
invite former chairman and vice chairman
of the council uh councillor dixon to
speak
thank you chairman
members will recall that
probably
two years ago it was that uh the
shakespeare hospice which became my
charity as the chairman of the council
were planning and organizing a 21 mile
walk from long compton to
stratford-by-haven
to celebrate their 21 years as being a
hospice
that event
david it was cancelled
i had volunteered as it were within my
vice chairmanship at that time to do the
21 mile walk uh in aid of the hospice
up upon becoming
instead of walking the 21 mile walk as
that had been by then postponed was to
do the 146 mile whole walk the
shakespeare way from the globe theater
to stratford
that too couldn't occur until at least
during covet etc
i am pleased to announce that the
shakespeare hospice have been able to
reorganize their 21 mile walk and it's
now scheduled for may the 8th which is a
sunday
but not just wanting to do the 21 mile
walk
i am going to join that 21 mile walk
having started from the globe some 10
days earlier
so my request to yourselves and i have
the various details of the website and
the charity for the shakespeare hospice
is if people would like to sponsor me
i would be very grateful i didn't have
many fundraising opportunities when i
was the chairman but here is a
good
charity a worthwhile charity it's 146
miles my target is
1460 pounds 10 pounds up per mile so i
would welcome all your support thank you
very much chairman
chairman if i can just come in after
councillor dixon there
tony weilstein i know you are addressing
the whole of the council can ask
councillors when they're speaking that
they they're speaking to their mics
themselves because you you are
your wise words were fading in and out
for our audience at home so if you when
you are speaking if you can speak
directly into the mice i'd be much
appreciated thank you
i'm not telling you off
great thank you um item five so we
haven't received any
um
questions from uh members of the public
so moving on to item six the proposed
loan to spring housing association for
the fred winter center um please could i
invite councillor harvey to introduce
this report
thank you mr chairman
at its meeting on the 7th february
2022 the cabinet considered an urgent
item of business
in relation to the finances of the
spring housing association
which has been leading the initiative to
create the fred winter center
a multi-disciplinary community hub the
purpose of which will be to provide a
broad range of needs of some of those
within the district who find themselves
homeless
during the development phase of this
project additional costs of some four
hundred thousand pounds have had to be
incurred because of the consequence of
the grenfell fire and the consequential
changes in fire safety requirements
spring housing association has been able
to allocate more of its own funds
towards the project
and has also secured additional funding
from homes england
there remains however a shortfall of 185
000 pounds which the cabinet was asked
to consider
providing as a loan to the spring
housing association
having regard to the need within the
district for such a facility
to the advanced stage the project has
reached
mindful of the 348 000 pounds that the
council has already spent in the current
financial year on the provision of bed
and bread bed and breakfast
accommodation
and reassured by the review by the
council's section 151 officer of spring
housing association's financial position
members of the cabinet indicated their
support to recommend to council that a
loan of 185 thousand pounds to spring
housing association at a rate of
interest of two percent to be repaid
over a period of two years
should two and a half years big pardon
should be made
councillors are asked therefore to
approve the recommendation set out in
the paper that this loan is provided as
outlined to enable the fred winter
centre to be completed and opened in the
spring of 2022. thank you mr chairman
thank you and i'll see you seconder
uh councillor parker
um are there any other members who'd
like to speak
on this
no we all agreed let's move with that
lovely thank you
uh item seven a statement so i'd like to
invite the lead of the council and then
a representative from the liberal
democrat group to make step statements
to the council as a reminder group
leaders are allowed up to ten minutes
for their statements
i'm not going to go into the details of
the budget that will be covered by my
colleague councillor harvey
what i want to do is make a few key
points that set the context in which we
created the budget
and pick up a couple of areas seldom
considered in the budget speeches
so our key points
once again we've only had a one year
settlement
this makes planning for the medium term
particularly challenging
we also need to fully understand the
constraints we face in setting a budget
we have to maintain a minimum reserve
requirement 2.5 million
we just stay within that limit at the
end of five years
a very important consideration
furthermore council tax increases are
capped in our case at five pounds which
equates to three point three percent
we're facing an economic butt cloth of
uncertainty in volatility
consumer price inflation the
government's preferred measure is now
five point five percent
a year ago is below one percent
we'll skip swiftly over the fact that
the retail prices index is currently
showing an increase of seven point eight
percent
the assumptions underpinning our budget
don't fully take into account this level
of inflation
and remember
most of the work on the budget was
completed prior to christmas last year
we also need to remember the 54
proposed increase in the energy price
cap is not yet reflected in the
inflation figures
increasing inflation
could easily impact on our spending
during this coming financial year
in addition the change in the projected
trajectory of interest rates over the
past past few months has been equally
rapid
six months ago it was thought we may
have seen a rate rise of 0.25 percent
in 2022
but further increases wouldn't happen
until 2023
we're now looking at five or even six
further increases during this year
it just shows how rapidly things are
changing at the moment
i would also say that i well recollect
the cries of anguish from the opposition
when we introduce the green waste charge
it should be obvious
that without the introduction of that
charge then there would have to be
literally a bonfire of services to
balance the budget over the five years
the impact that that clearly
demonstrates the importance of taking a
strategic and long-term view
the five-year time horizon does actually
give us a very important discipline
the impact of the waste and recycling
services reflected elsewhere in the
accounts
the 6.1 million in the capital programme
for the materials recycling center and
the first trance was paired in january
22.
again this reflects a very sensible
strategic decision taken by this council
there is also four and a half million in
the capital budget for our share of
procure
for our share of procuring the vehicles
needed to deliver the joint waste
contract
again and not insignificant some but we
have to remember it's cheaper for us to
borrow the money and invest than it is
for biffa
we've also invested 3.1 billion in
leisure center improvements to provide
better facilities for our residents
there's one area of council activities
that always seems to escape mention
i'm going to correct that now
what many people don't realize is all
the work of the council operates
routinely under the radar
so far in
2021 22 we've paid out
73 million supporting 13 different curvy
grant schemes
and reliefs to over 7 000 businesses
14 and a half million in housing benefit
to up to over 3 000 households for those
on the lowest incomes
6.8 million in local council tech
support
for over 5 and a half thousand
households on the lowest incomes
four hundred and seventy three thousand
to nine hundred and forty seven cases
applying for test and tries payments
linked to covered
giving the numbers above the total
almost 95 million
it's not difficult to imagine the
positive impact on the residents of the
district
i would say that we've had excellent
feedback
much of it from businesses
about the performance of the teams
delivering these grants
i am sure you will all join me in
commending their work
so there you have it
sound strategic decisions
enabling us to continue to provide
valuable
services substantial capital investment
to underpin and enhance future delivery
of services
and most important a prudent budget
created in the teeth of uncertainty
unpredictable
unpredictability and volatility
and residents get all of this for
proposed council tax of only 154 pounds
and 12 pence
thank you
thank you in the uh democrat
uh i'm going to nominate councillor
curtis to talk on our on our group's
behalf
thank you chair
thank you council jefferson
firstly on behalf of the liberal
democrats group i'd like to thank the
officers for their hard work and
expertise in producing this report and
for their guidance and support in
producing our liberal democrat
amendments it is appreciated
and i'd personally especially like to
thank mike snow for his input thank you
mike
we live in difficult times the financial
climate for this council and families
and businesses in our district is
uncertain and as councillor jefferson
just eloquently said planning for the
future has been made even more difficult
for the council this year owing to the
government's decision to give no more
than a single year's financial
settlement
this of course leads to short-termism
which is never helpful
residents face many challenges these
include
increases in the cost of living
as has been alluded to mention or
mentioned massive hikes and energy
prices inflation at its highest for 30
years an increase
in national insurance contributions for
self-employed of nearly 14 percent
at the same time people of all ages and
circumstances are experiencing the
long-term effects of covid on health
well-being and education
the the lib dems tackling climate change
affordable housing support for residents
in greatest need
and economic recovery are absolutely our
highest priorities
and we should take every opportunity to
address these issues
and to find additional resources where
necessary
and our response to the administration's
budget proposals reflect this view
given that at this time last year
the council underestimated its funding
from central government by 3.1 million
we question whether the proposed cuts
set out in this budget are really
necessary
in the current circumstances perhaps we
should be taking the opportunity to
invest in the district's future and
build back better if i can say that
the liberal democrats urged council to
declare a climate emergency one of the
breaks on addressing carbon consumption
is public awareness of the urgency of
the situation and the second constraint
is the sense that the public have of
their ability to influence such a
significant global issue
we have proposed the creation of a
community climate change fund modeled on
the successful south cambridgeshire zero
carbon communities fund
and grant funding of a hundred thousand
pounds would empower local community
groups supporting them to help council
achieve its net zero budget
moving on to housing
while there are record-breaking numbers
of new homes being built in the district
as reported recently in the herald
there remains a chronic shortage of
affordable housing to meet local needs
we therefore urge the council to
continue the funding for the rural in a
housing enabler post which will help to
address this issue particularly in rural
awards
legislation to encourage self-built and
custom-built homes requires the council
to maintain a district register of
interest to ensure sufficient land
supply for this purpose i believe there
are currently 232 entries on the
register
councils are permitted to charge for
this service and warwick district
council currently charges 50 pounds for
initial registration and 20 pounds per
year thereafter helping cover costs of
this obligation
we propose that a similar charge by
stratford which would contribute
more than 10 000 pounds would help fund
a a robust and thorough process in order
to ensure that applicants are genuinely
seeking self-build plots in the district
and that the register accurately
reflects local housing needs
returning to ways in which we can
support
people living with greatest need
counsellors know
that residents who use shop mobility
service are already disadvantaged
and a greater proportion likely to be
more vulnerable to covid
they will have been disproportionately
affected by the pandemic
and
while the cabinet report on the revenue
budget states on page 15 sections 9 11
and 13 that and i quote
there are no implications for the
environment equalities or health and
well-being arising from these proposals
no implications for the environment
equalities or health and well-being
curious the liberal democrats suggest
that budget setting
should be an opportunity to actively
improve
environment equalities
health and well-being
for our residents cutting support for
this this service will only make things
more difficult for people living in
hardship
rather than reducing services for people
with disabilities liberal democrats want
to work with our partnership with our
partners
and colleagues at warwick district
council
to improve the lives of people with
living with a disability
finally i turn to the question of
economic recovery
councillors know that this district was
the first fourth worst hit authority in
the country and we also know that
tourism is a key stone of our economy
in 2018 the total value of tourism to
the district
was over
461 million pounds
accounting for 15 percent of employment
or 6287
full-time equivalent jobs
it's a significant sector desperately in
need of a recovery that's going to take
many years
it thus seems perverse
to close the visitor information center
which provides a valuable resource for
visitors from the uk and abroad and
domes would like to see this proposal
withdrawn
government funding to local authorities
has been reduced by 50
since 2011.
compounding this the proportion of
funding to local authorities awarded
through the bidding processes has arisen
has risen and these schemes are highly
competitive
and whilst neighboring authorities have
made successful bids for example
lemington secured 10 million and uneaten
13 million pounds for the free from the
future high streets fund
bidding for such grants
is both time consuming and requires
particular skills in-depth knowledge of
the processes and projects most likely
to be successful is vital
we would like therefore to see the
recruitment of a new senior business
support and development officer for a
fixed two-year contract
council officers have worked extremely
hard to submit bids and our proposal is
no criticism of them at all it simply
reflects the increasing reliance on such
schemes and the need for greater
capacity
reflecting the comments that counselor
jefferson has made about a strategic and
long-term view we feel this will be a
sound strategic investment assisting
with the economic recovery of the
district at such a time as this more
than ever it is vital that we prioritize
what is most important for our residents
i therefore urge councillors to consider
the proposed amendments from the liberal
democrats
for their potential to
improve economic recovery
support our most vulnerable residents
increase affordable housing and address
the climate change emergency
these lie at the heart of what is needed
for our residents and our businesses in
our district thank you
thank you
um
so i'm just going to propose the
following that's council procedure rule
15.5 so when a counselor may speak again
to be waived to allow one nominated
member from each group to speak more
than once
on the budget related items so just seek
a second of these
council dixon and we need to do a vote
don't we
okay all agreed
perfect
okay so
meet uh moving on to item eights um
the revenue and capital budget um just
want to inform the council that the
meeting in accordance with the local
authorities standing orders england
amendment regulations 2014 that are
recorded votes will be taken on the
revenue and capital budget uh for years
2022 2023 um please my i invite
councillor harvey as portfolio holder
for resources to introduce this item
thank you mr chairman
the leader has outlined much of the
context against which we've developed
this particular budget
i make no apologies for amplifying some
of the points he's made and they
demonstrate the challenges we face and
will continue to face
the economic backdrop to the preparation
of the budget for the next financial
year is very mixed
internationally there's the risk of war
in europe
and the major disruptive repercussions
of all sorts to which that could lead
domestically we suffered the economic
and social consequences of covet 19
pandemic over the past two years
the government has borrowed prodigious
amounts of money to meet the costs to
the nhs of treating those who've fallen
ill
and of the vaccination program that has
protected so many
vast amounts of money have been borrowed
to meet the cost of the furlough scheme
that protected so many jobs and the cost
of providing financial support to
businesses throughout the country that
have helped to sustain so many of them
the leader in his speech made reference
to the 95 million pounds distributed by
this district which showed the scale of
the support given
in 2019 to 20 the british economy
suffered its most pronounced recession
for 300 years
from which it has in very large measure
although not completely now rebounded
there are currently of the order of 1.25
1.25 million vacant jobs in the uk
with record high levels of vacancies
across 15 of the uk's 18 industry
sectors
the tightness of the labor market
particularly in those sectors that have
traditionally been amongst the least
well paid are now showing predictable
signs of pressure for increases in
salary settlements
this is particularly the case given
what's happened to the rate of increase
of the cpi
i make no apologize
i don't make no apologies for
reinforcing what the leader said about
the levels of uncertainty
at this time of year february 2021
consumer prices were increasing at the
rate of
0.4
per annum the latest cpi figures for
january 2022 indicate that prices rose
by 5.5
its highest rate since march
1992.
the rate of increase of the cpi
projected by the bank of england driven
by energy costs and supply chain
bottlenecks amongst other factors
is that it may reach seven percent by
april of this year
the office of budget responsibility is
charged with responsibility for giving
the government independent advice on the
public finances it expects cpi to rise
in the second half of 2022 before coming
back to target relatively quickly
however
the obr recognizes that there are
current currently significant risks
around this inflation forecast
added to this
is the recent increase in interest rates
and the common expectation that they
will continue to rise over the next two
years
it's against this mixed background of
the uk economy's relative recovery from
a sharp recession
coupled with coupled with an
acceleration in the rate of inflation
that was not wholly anticipated
and the largest squeeze on living
standards for a generation
that the proposed revenue and capital
budget is recommended for approval by
council the council's finances for the
current year demonstrate the
uncertainties with which the council has
had to cope for example the revenue
generated by the introduction of the
garden waste scheme that the liberal
democrat group voted against this time
last year
exceeded all expectations
on the other hand
the council has had to cope with the
logistical and cost implications arising
from the fire at the eddington recycling
plant
the medium-term financial strategy set
on pay set out on page 73 of the papers
considered as item five of the cabinets
meeting on the seventh of february
shows that the estimated financial
result of the council's activities this
year will be a deficit
of 802 000 pounds
this will need to be financed from
reserves
given the vagaries and uncertainties of
the past year this outcome is not
unsurprising
the underlying strategic financial issue
the council faces however is the
changing structure of the sources of its
revenue
this year's spending review was the
proverbial cure its egg
the very the review was another
disappointment because for the fourth
consecutive year it produced a
settlement for a single year rather than
what had previously been the case a
settlement for a four year period
this means that local authorities lack
the certainty of their financial
framework for a reasonable period over
which they can then plan
that said
the picture that i've tried to paint
about the uncertainties the british
economy currently faces
is the real world
it's the real world background against
which government 30 seconds judgments
this spending review did however
have some good news for the district at
this time last year it was anticipated
that the demise of the new homes bonus
would mean that in the next financial
year the district would receive 1.3
million pounds under this heading
as a result of the spending review the
amount the district will receive will be
3.8 billion pounds
what this means is that the potential
reductions in the council's expenditure
that we discussed last year can again be
held in abeyance until the details of
whatever is to replace new homes bonus
unknown in detail
whilst this is good news in the short
term for our ability to continue to
finance the council's current range and
level of service provision the pressure
on the council's finances to fund its
services beyond the next financial year
remains undiminished
that said councillors will have noted
that the budget proposed is for a small
deficit of a hundred and sixteen
thousand pounds and that it is also
proposed to re release three hundred and
eight uh
three hundred and eighteen thousand
pounds of earmarked reserves to
contribute to the funds available for
next year thank you we can wrap it up in
a moment please
i will leave it at that
thank you so much
um so firstly it's going to take a point
from councillor fragile who i missed
before
so item seven was budget statements and
then one from each side we're now on
item eight
i don't think councilman harvey got as
far as proposing the budget yesterday i
think i think well i'll invite
councillor harvey to propose the budget
then they'll be open for debate after
it's been seconded thank you thank you
thank you so now i would like to seek a
proposal for councillor harvey
if you want to propose that
i propose the budget thank you and a
second to please
councillor jefferson
thank you um council junaid
can i first of all thank um the the
cabinet for taking one of our
suggestions on board uh which was the
help for um
local residents with um help with energy
and finance advice uh going forward in
the coming year for the fifty thousand i
thank you for that because
it's certainly going to be it's already
been noticed by me as a ward member that
there is a lot of people who are facing
um at
debt and financial hardship and the more
that we prevent people getting into a
state of financial hardship the more
they will be able to pay their council
tax their rents etc and and prevent
hardship further hardship going forward
so i suggest i thank you for that
can i note
that um i also raised at the cabinet and
at the ovu and scrutiny committee that
this is the fourth one-year settlement
in a row which does not help with
financial planning and financial
sustainability
and i know i noted that there were
rising costs but i also noted that i
wrote to the local mp
as a leader of a district council group
i have yet
one month on i have yet to have a reply
from that mp
about what he thought about my letter
and it was a very all i did was reflect
the local government association's
official view on the inability of
councils to plan properly and
successfully if they did not get a
multi-year settlement and i asked him to
take that up and take it up with the
ministers concerned and i've yet to get
a response
and i also address certain things about
the economy
i actually took the trouble to read
the government's leveling up white paper
interesting reading it made too
it outlines a lot of problems such as
the endemic policy churn under
utilization of local knowledge poor
institutional memory in central
governments failures to cultivate local
leadership as well etc etc
but it also made a very strong point
about the multiple competitive pots of
money and the bidding process
and it said that it was inefficient and
it resulted in um burdens on local
authorities
with limited resources that they it that
the local government had a lack of
capacity to navigate multiple funding
pots
develop investable projects get the
right mix of capital and revenue to
target long-term priorities
it made a very good case indeed for what
i've put in what we've put into our
budget about making sure that we um
stand up for local businesses
the short bidding time scales prevent uh
council spin from being as successful as
they might be
but unfortunately by chapter three
all that had been forgotten
the policy framework that was in in
there made no mention whatsoever
of reforming the bidding processes even
though
they cope with that going forward
and that is why we need to strengthen
our officers and make sure that they can
deal with that going forward
because we have high streets in
that are in trouble
we have
local businesses that are having to cope
with national insurance tax rises
we know that local government has the so
the expertise and the economic and
social expertise if they were allowed to
be able to develop it fully
the lga put a study forward
on behalf of all local authorities
highlighting the importance of
evidence-based approaches
community engagement business engagement
and the right staff for councils
and it also emphasized that councils
have to build capacity
to prepare and craft funding bids
and it said
that contracting consultants can be
useful but is not sustainable
particularly when there's a need to
connect internally and with partners
across departments
and it made a very good case for what we
have proposed
i hope
cabinet i hope councillors that you will
take the time to read some of the
criticisms that's made of government in
the way in which they are planning
economic strategy and economic recovery
and think about how we might uh
go forward
and can i just say one last thing which
is in our budget but is not actually an
amendment for um
finance that i would like to see
as part of this council
much more attention paid to looking at
all the amount reserves going forward
over the next year or so to be regularly
reviewed and justified
on all levels of section one on success
section 106 and still that's in the
reserve to be reviewed unjustified and
make sure that this council is run on
good quality economic basis thank you
thank you
so just first of all can i just get a
nomination from the conservative group
on who's going to speak twice please
counselor harvey's being pointed out
great and the liberal democrat group
please counselor junit great thank you
just um a query are you proposing
this as a as a motion counselor june ed
an amendment
great so please might have a second uh
please for council junets proposal
counselor curtis
right so now we're going to debate um
the amendment so would anyone like to
speak counselor jenny fragile
thank you chair um i just like to make
uh comment on shop mobility because shop
mobility is an asset to this town and to
this district
and provides a service not only for
residents but for the many visitors that
we have
which are as we've already heard
essential to the economic health of this
town towns in this district and the
district itself
over a thousand users per annum
for little cost to the council
are we an inclusive town
or are we ignoring one in four of our
population with a disability
the hard work of the shop mobility staff
shows already shows a small profit
and with improvements to the system
already suggested
by friends of stratford shop mobility it
could be far better
it's not right to compare
stratford shop mobility to warwick
district mobility i believe that they
have a grant of some uh 25 000 pounds
which they receive from warwick district
council
i understand also
that stratford shop mobility
was
told that they could have a meeting to
discuss
shop mobility finances and its viability
before this was going to be set in the
budget and my understanding is that this
meeting hasn't actually taken place
so if this is actually going to go
forward and be voted on at the very
least an immediate invitation to the
friends of shot mobility should be made
so that this um
i think very poor decision can be
explained
thank you chair
thank you councillor pertiguella
yeah thank you chair
um the liberal democrat group wants to
make absolutely clear that we are
against any closure of the visitor
information center and we are baffled
that this is even proposed considering
the setbacks that the tourist and
hospitality trades have seen in the last
two years visitors information centers
are like ambassadors for their local
areas
we recognize the challenges but also the
opportunities in a post-pandemic
district
what we would welcome is a bold and
fresh vision for the visitors
information center which should which
should play a pivotal role in any future
cultural and place strategy
indeed the main role of such center is
to bring prosperity and well-being to
our residents the center should promote
the local economy through a model of
sustainable tourism which positively
impacts local residents and the
environment
such vision will see the center become
an important cultural infrastructure in
the new local plan
through my involvement with the local
arts scene i can see firsthand the
wealth of talent over artists and
crafters and the center could be another
place to showcase this talent a made in
stratford or perhaps a made in
southwestern site for local visitors and
those farther afield to find out about
the work of our wonderful makers
this vision must have an eye to the
wider district with a visitor
information center or even multiple
microsites or tourist apps working
closely with town and parish councils as
well museums and libraries and local
businesses to promote areas to discover
and explore outside the honeypot
locations
in particular the district's rural areas
from roman ulster to shipstone with its
important role in britain's woolen
industry to studly for many centuries
capital of neither manufacturing and not
forgetting are important natural and
historical landscapes including the
warrior cotswolds the avon valley the
locations linked to the gunpowder plot
and the english civil war the many more
beautiful and proud
towns villages and hamlets including
those in my world thank you
thank you council jefferson
thank you chair
i would like to pick up on some of the
points that have been raised
first
closure of the visitor information
center
that is not going to happen this year
it gives us time to review it
the other thing i would just say in
terms of tourism
there's a hundred thousand in this year
and next year to support shakespeare's
england
we will well recognize the value of
tourism which is why we are putting 200
000 over two years
into shakespeare's england
when it comes to shop mobility
again
that is not closing this year
it gives time to review the scheme
what i would say on all of these things
they will be very dependent on the
settlement we get next year which should
be for four years
we do not as yet know how much we will
get
and there may well be
some uncomfortable decisions to take
i would also say
that
where we are looking
at
uh the self build that is already in
train we are looking at charging for
that
the fact that it may not be in the
budget does not mean we are not working
on certain things
i would also
say
that we are investing
half a million this year and next year
and
we have to recognize once again
we are doing this
because we think it is important
there is nothing in the years after next
year because we have no idea what the
settlement will be
we have to be prudent
we have to look at the reality on the
ground in terms of what we face in terms
of funding
i think we have done that
as
a council in putting this budget
together
and i would
accept
the liberal democrat proposal on
practical energy and finance advice for
residents given what residents face
i am quite happy with that i think it is
a good proposal but
how we spend it will need to be
justified it's the same with the money
in for climate change
the spending of that money will need a
business case and will need to be
justified we are not just going to throw
money at everything
the question about extra support for
businesses
75 000
given what i outlined earlier
we spent 73 million
supporting businesses
75 000 frankly just bounces off
there's been much made of an officer to
support bids
there will be a paper going to the next
cabinet because there was a notice of
motion about bids
that will actually address this fully
what i would say is bidding for things
is
complex it's not easy
i have to say i concur with some of the
points that are in the leveling up white
paper
however
what i would also say that that cabinet
paper will i am sure demonstrate just
how successful we have been
in succeeding in the bidding process
across a whole number of areas
so with that
i will stop thank you
thank you councilorcock
thank you
thank you mr chairman um
thank you council jefferson for your
comment set about shop mobility and the
tourist information
i understand nothing is going it's
nothing's going to close this year
that is a
that is the sword of donald dude if i
ever heard it it is hanging over their
heads and they know there is a strong
possibility of closure
for the residents who have contacted me
especially about shop mobility
it's a terrifying prospect you are
putting them in
the people who use the shop mobility and
will use it frequently is because they
don't have the space in their homes to
store a disability scooter
so they use the shop mobility to hire
one as and when they need taking that
away from them means that these people
will miss out
they'll miss out coming to visit our
town
i have one resident who's very concerned
because she goes into the town she uses
the mobility scooter
to visit her son in the cemetery
because she doesn't have she can't drive
having a taxi works out too expensive
but being able to get to the shop
mobility it means she can do it and she
can do it independently
you have a mother with fibromyalgia
seven out of out of 30 days she might be
fine but in that one day
when her son's working on something in
stratford town center
she can't go because there's no shop
mobility for her to hire a scooter from
i know it's easy to look at a figure on
a page
and it's easy to look at shop mobility
and not see it but these are people
and these are residents of stratford
who need the support of this council
yes i understand
it will be reviewed in the year
council a year isn't enough
for what you are wanting
which is what shop mobility to become
self-sufficient to be fundraising
themselves so
no support from the council
that could be possible but it's not
going to be possible in 12 months time
you have to give them the opportunity
to fight for the service that they need
these are human beings
they're people who deserve to have
support from their council
i would strongly suggest that counselors
look at this and look at the human
aspect not just the figures on the page
thank you
thank you uh councillor bromwich
yeah obviously look down this
lit then proposals with great interest
first thing we have to realize we have
been mentioned here about our over
reliance almost on the tourism industry
we as a council have got to start
looking at diversifying
away from just a central focal point yes
at the moment it makes up a large part
of our economy but if we've been guilty
of anything over a number years it's not
diversifying enough away from that so
maybe we should start thinking outside
the box a little bit not just a big
focus on tourism
other points i note on this um carbon
zero fund
now it's all right
i wanted to spend 125 000 on that but um
there are ways that that money could be
better spent for example
you could look at um
spending money on reverse vending
machines which would generate revenue
for the council give a typical price
right for five units around about 40 000
pounds
surely things like that are better to
look at than sort of
putting a pot of money there and it's
not really going to generate us
practical uses at the moment
yes we do need to make residents aware
about climate change and how they can be
helped to make things more
environmentally friendly
and
lots of things we as councillors could
do but do we really need 125 000 pounds
on that i think
things like that can be spent better
elsewhere
i note also the interest about the shop
mobility
now yes i know it's very emotive and can
be for a place like stratford but when
we start getting to the towns and
villages
they'll be turning around saying to us
is it relevant for us we can't get our
motability scooter on higher on demand
maybe again it's not a case of scrapping
a scheme but looking how we encompass
more residents these are sorts of
arguments that we really need to think
of rather than just chucking money at
the problem
we're a big district we're a lot of
diverse community
we are not always spending our money in
the best ways
maybe we need to start having some very
awkward conversations rather than
throwing money at problems and working
out what's best for
lots of residents rather than focal
point areas and if i'm very critical of
the lib dense proposal it again suggests
that now more focus on the elections of
stratfor than across the district
as a council we can put party politics
aside we can all work together
we can look at ways of actually
utilizing the money we got
very well
but sometimes it's not about political
points going it's about looking at
realities
so when we look at business needs
yes we look at certain size businesses
but quite often we forget about the
lower income single operators now again
a lot of these grants have never
been
acceptable to these through government
legislation that that they let's face
small businesses and smaller own owners
can't apply for these grants or not
eligible so again it's about why would
we set 75 000 pounds for that when it
might be that that company might just
need a 500 pound grant and that may be a
bit better than
spending money that way it's about
thinking a bit smarter
whilst they're very noble proposals
sometimes we have to think smarter
rather than just looking at headline
figures so because i can't support these
amendments on here but i think certainly
we need to start throwing a lot of
bigger debate into things and in the
next 12 months start getting a bit more
imagination creating an innovation into
this and we need to all sit down whether
it be conservative lib dems independent
screens we need to have very serious
hard discussions
thank you councillor junette
i did some research from the house of
commons library uh over 2000 small bit
and medium-sized enterprises within this
district will be affected by the
national insurance contributions rise
it will be the second highest in the
whole of the country
5.5 million rise from the additional tax
from april 22 to this year this this
coming year
that just it just illustrates the burden
that will be put on to our small
businesses within this district
and recognizing that many of those
businesses
are businesses that are on our high
streets
where
particularly in small rural towns
they'll be particularly impacted
many of those businesses are going to
face a real squeeze in their income in
2022 along with the rising living costs
and continuing pandemic uncertainty
i know that many of you will have seen
shops closing on your high streets and
small businesses closing around the area
they do need support from this council
as well as from government
but just looking at the community zero
carbon fund which has just been
criticized
we have to be able to take communities
with us when we are discussing climate
change
we have to look at some of the costs of
community-centered initiatives across
the district in all our villages in all
our towns
i know that in here in stratfor the
shrottery village hall was trying to
raise money i know that in ulster the
greg hall is trying to raise money to
try to make sure that they are energy
efficient and have got renewables on on
their site
i had note that the harbory village hall
has done an excellent job
and i've listened to many of those
village halls and they keep telling me
and i've spoken to about five or six of
them
that sometimes all they need is much
funding for all the costs paid for an
initial energy audit and then they can
apply to other sources of funding to be
able to get some of the um they work the
grants that they need to do the work but
they just cannot get onto that ladder
because they can't get the initial
energy ordered
many times if you want to take the
community with you it is able to it's
the ability to be able to show what is
done and show how it works and village
halls are very good ways of doing that
and that's certainly been the case with
harbory where they've been able to show
not only how energy efficiency works and
insulation works but how electric
vehicle charging points outside the
village hall also works
and i think that you will
you know you will agree also that there
are some very good organizations
community organizations across the
district that want to do a lot more for
example on cycle infrastructure and a
lot of other things but they need a
helping hand to get them started and
they need somebody that will be able to
help them not just with major finance is
often just that initial
sum in order to be able to do much
funding
this council actually helped me in
ulster they managed to give me a matched
funding of 20 000 pounds that enabled me
to be able to go to various other grants
with a small community group and raise
25 000 pounds for a play area this
illustrates the power of communities if
they are given that initial helping hand
but sometimes they just need something
to get them off the ground to start that
matched funding to find that energy
audit to start the work on the cycle
infrastructure to start something on on
vehicle uh electric vehicle charging
points to be able to do help their
village um their their local high street
whether it is through
um whether it is through uh funding for
uh pr promotion of high streets whether
it is to funding for some of the other
energy some of the other tourist uh
information that is around the area they
need that initial audit that initial
match funding
this is why it is in the liberal
democrat budget thank you
thank you councillor pemberton
thank you chairman
um
hands up any member here who wants to
spend less money and cut services
okay
we have to consider the proposals that
are in front of us and many of the aims
and asp
audible
but we have to consider
can they be delivered councillor junior
talks about
how we might support communities and and
cycle infrastructure
a pound can only be spent once
so they'll spend that we spend that
pound on the cycle infrastructure but we
spend the pound on supporting shop
mobility
it's not a great place to be but those
are some of the choices we have to make
um
if i talk about the zero carbon fund
when we've looked at all of these
proposals we've considered are they
how how well and how formed and how can
they be accommodated
and the answer is we've come to the
conclusion that only one of these
proposals can be accommodated within the
current framework okay
um i might i might observe that there
might be an opportunity for a business
case to be put forward through the
climate change panel for that and that
might be an opportunity to achieve
because we're trying to achieve but
we've got to be smart about it so that
might be a potential route
um
i look particularly at
the visitor information and shop
mobility
um councillor alcock i'm the chair of
trustees
for the coventry and warwickshire branch
of one of the largest well the largest
brain injury charity in the country
and i can assure you losing funding at
zero notice
is a lot harder than losing funding at
12 months notice and it's about how you
see it it's a bad opportunity there is
an opportunity over the next 12 months
to work with shop mobility to work
through visitor information to establish
that if we need to get to that point how
do we deliver those things smarter so
for example with with vic how do we
engage with the rsc how do we engage
with other organizations and and use
other outlets within the town and other
opportunities to achieve that so i would
urge both vic and shop mobility to see
this as an opportunity it is much better
to have 12 months potential lead time
and work to a target date than just to
be told that it's going at no notice and
i can assure certainly from my own
experience around grants and and things
like that so i would i would urge that
to be taken as the way forward um and
probably the other one i would just make
some comment on is around the extra
business support
we're talking about seventy five
thousand pounds over two years so that's
thirty seven and a half thousand a year
over one year i thought it was over two
years
okay
and presumably then that's a one's
looking for it you're looking for a
recurring
you're looking for a recurring spend um
i was one at 37 and a half thousand
you're not going to get the right kind
of person um i've struggled even at 75
in a year given on costs everything else
whether that's actually going to achieve
things that you're trying to achieve
the leader is absolutely right
it is
the notion that we are
entirely
underperforming around uh securing
grants is just that it's a notion um we
are more successful and i'll i'll leave
that in a balance until the the
consideration of the motion
but we are we are getting there on on
grants and you have to remember the
framework yes fourth worst affected but
the reality is that round one of levine
bid used the data pre-pandemic not post
so
it was always stacked against us
but we are looking at other ways to try
and secure funds for certain certain
grants and finally we talk about the 8.1
talks about the world's born air field
strategy just to pick up uh councillor
bromwich
the leader and other members of cabinet
are absolutely working hard on spreading
uh away from tourism
and if
what we hope comes to transpire on
wellsborne i think you'll you will see
that demonstrated amply
my final point would be um i'm i'm not
really think we should be prepared to
think about well um we may be able to
release this i think we need to be
certain about when and if we're going to
be able to release funds because there's
no point
creating false expectation uh by uh
releasing em after reserves early only
then to find you've got a retrench we
all want to deliver the highest value
best possible widest services that we
can as a council but the reality is we
work within some serious constraints uh
and i think that this budget should be
commended as um the most appropriate way
of delivering as far as as we can the
aspirations of all members thank you
thank you council for check
thank you chair
uh yeah i'd like to support these um
amendments by the liberal democrats i
think they're they're all very sensible
um proposals
and um
quite clearly they
they i'm convinced they'll work and
they'll work well so they're very
sensible proposals to be put forward
um and then they're not big spending
proposals um either um
and just to pick up the point of council
of
bromwich
he was sort of saying accusing the lib
dems of being stratford-centric
well every single one of these proposals
is of benefit to the district as a whole
apart from
not wanting the council to close the
tourism visitor center and shop ability
and just to touch on the tourism visitor
center
i think we probably all realize that
shakespeare
used to live in this town um and
tourism is quite important
and we get millions of visitors as a
result and in the future we'll be um
going back to having those millions of
overseas visitors and domestic visitors
and
the sooner it happens the better and i'm
sure we all welcome that
so visitor center makes economic sense
to actually stay open so that's just a
business case
and then just on the other point of the
shop mobility
i think we all have values here in this
room
and our values
are what
our values
i think it's it's about how we treat
the most vulnerable in in our town and
in the district
and um if people
with a disability are putting are being
put at a disadvantage
over people who are able-bodied then i
think that may say something about our
values
about that i'll finish thank you
thank you councillor adam
you chairman um
i will of course support the amendment
um for
many reasons that my uh my colleagues
have set out i do
find it slightly odd going into the the
issues of shop mobility and the tourist
center uh closure being somewhat
deferred in terms of the actual time
scale whereas the um
proposed charge for self-build um
register inclusion which is an easy
proportional and fair um charge that we
could include now um is something that
is being put off for another day i think
that's something that we can absolutely
uh look at in a more immediate term
which would allow us to have our
system working better for our residents
and for the processes that we have um
and also to pick up on the points um
that were raised about the being
stratfor centric now out in the far east
where um where i am um this is often a
concern that we do have in making sure
that we do represent the whole district
i think um what's being put down here
reed does seek to
work for the whole district particularly
in relation to the community zero carbon
fund which i've seen through my work as
a parish councillor and working with my
parish councils
can make a real difference even as just
a
a way to kickstart things to get moving
i have a very active parish councillor
in my ward who is working on exactly
this type of thing and how it can be
implemented with a small amount of um
injection of cash this is a brilliant
idea for being able to do that in and
not including it at this time i think is
uh is falling short of what we really
hoped for when we talked about declaring
a climate emergency that's why i will be
supporting it thank you
thank you council harvey
could i be reminded how long i've got to
what guidance
um
i think context is everything uh in this
discussion i don't uh question the
motives of various counselors who've
spoken but i just come back to
some uh
cancer holcock uh urged us not to
consider just the numbers
i'm afraid however we're considering a
budget and there are certain constraints
and the budget has to balance and the
section 151 officer has to be satisfied
that it does balance and the reserve
position that he regards as a minimum
is always kept so the bottom line is the
numbers i'm afraid do count in the
context of this discussion
um
i i i'll make this point hesitatingly
because i don't wish to make this unduly
uh party political
but
had the decision not been taken to
introduce the garden waste scheme last
year this council's finances would have
been short by about two million pounds
and we wouldn't be considering at this
meeting proposals how do we spend more
we would have to be discussing how we
spend much less much less two million
pounds this year the next year the next
year the next year and the next year for
the five-year strategy
the point that we uh where we're really
at is that this year
2000
2021 we will report sorry 2122.
we will report for the council the
deficit of the order of eight hundred
thousand pounds this budget is broadly
balanced but shows a small deficit for
next year
resources are tight
the questions of if we want to spend
more in one direction amounts to well
tell me what you want to spend less in
another so if you want to spend under a
hundred thousand pounds
on
a zero carbon fund
are we considering reducing our spend
towards shakespeare's england to nil
from 100 000 pounds
when you get into office and you have to
deal with the finances as they really
are those are the sort of questions you
have to face and you have to be prepared
to answer
there are certain things which i just
don't i don't i don't
get in this uh in these proposals
shop mobility
is a discretionary service as far as i'm
aware
we don't have to do it we do do it
because we value it we did it last year
we did it this year we're proposing to
do it next year would we like to do it
forever more i suspect the answer most
councils would say yes while the needs
there that's fine we would like to do it
the visitor center the count the the
leader of the council had an article
published
in the herald last week in his column
where he pointed out that there are
people in this town
who think that tourists will always come
the complacent attitude that tourists
inevitably will always come to stratford
well that's why we need a visitor center
to make sure that when they do arrive
they know where to go what to see and
what to visit
we value the information center do we
want to see carry on yes course we do
will we do so as long as we have the
finances to do it that's the issue do we
have the finances to do it
[Music]
there is an implication
in
in
a number of these which which i find
frankly distasteful so the for instance
the question of reviewing
the earmarked reserves
the implication is that we don't do that
section 151 officer may correct me but
if i'm not uh mistaken we have already
gone through earmarked reserves and have
transferred from earmarked to general
reserves over two million pounds in
order to be able to carry on funding the
council in the way it has
so i i resent the implication that we
are negligent and don't do these things
that that officers aren't diligent in
their work that's the implication and i
frankly it gets up my nose
bottom line is that on we we to show
that we are reasonable people
uh on this side of the fence
the the proposal to spend fifty thousand
pounds and allocated for an advice
function we we think in current
circumstances is is totally justifiable
and we are prepared to do that and
subject to a good business case we are
prepared to see money put down that
particular direction so it's not as if
we're partisan but we do recognize the
circumstances where we are where we
really are
and on that basis i urge you to support
the uh proposal that this budget is
supported and these amendments are
rejected
thank you council shenson
thank you chairman uh i just wanted to
pick up on a couple of uh
specific points that have been raised
about um
the community zero carbon fund and
village halls etc
uh something that um we've been working
on
uh of late is attracting funding
for uh to train uh people and uh in
villages
uh and to be able to
and the climate change panel are
probably aware of this but not everyone
else's
uh
we had a an interview about two weeks
ago
with uh about eight people online
where we had to pitch
for
uh some serious funding
to train us and train a number of
uh people within villages within
districts to take forward climate change
um
uh if you like climate change
initiatives and to signpost uh villages
and village halls and parish councils
town councils
it's where funding will be
we were successful we found we had
confirmation of that at the weekend
and
uh we will be working very hard on that
uh unfortunately having a chance to to
to
put this out to everyone
so it's not
it's not that we uh we won't be doing
anything with with uh villages and
etc far from it we will be doing a lot
but what we need uh are experts to help
us
to get the message out and i
for my sins um as i've once what's once
said is a i i
write at the the start of this uh
well right back in 2019 said i'm just a
boring accountant
what do i know about communication
most accountants are accused of having
charisma bypasses so um i think
nobody needs i don't need it i don't
need any response back from that so the
um so the point is that we are we are
doing something
the other thing i will point out is that
we have been successful in getting
grants under the lads scheme for
insulation
um we are waiting and building up
a a a base we are waiting for funding
through the buildback greener initiative
unfortunately that's that's that
initiative that paper that came out
before christmas was was high on high
level detail and very low on
very high on aspirations very low on
detail on how the funding would come uh
forward but we will be competing for
those so it's not it the reason why the
community zero carbon fund uh
suggestion here of 125 000 pounds is not
acceptable to me is because we're doing
other things
to to that that will make better use of
that kind of money it's been mentioned
that
parish councils and town councils want
match funding
to date i have to say i haven't heard
seen any uh application from uh through
the climate change panel from from any
town council
for any kind of funding at all so um i'm
not saying that we would even consider
it
because
with so many town and parish councils
it would dilute the money that we have
got
but we will be coming out we will be
having a road show we will be going out
it's not so
that matter will be resolved so i would
uh like uh
councillor harvey would say that
apart from the 50 000
the proposal should be rejected
and the budget accepted
thank you very much
thank you councillor junaid
can i just say um
that i was actually the leader of this
council that introduced shock mobility
to this district
uh and um in a way i therefore have an
interest there i was also the leader
that actually introduced what was the
precursor to act on energy and i have
declared an interest on that because i
still remain a trustee so actually i've
had some pretty good ideas in the past
and i've actually been successful and
this district council and this district
has benefited from them
what i am trying to say is that this
council needs to be better prepared in
many many ways and it's not this
council's fault it is the fault of the
way in which government
puts its funding and puts its policies
and we do need to get that message
across to government that that's not a
good way to do things but we are where
we are uh and uh councillor pemberton
hasn't actually illustrated how a lack
of up-to-date data can be a crucial part
of not being able to get a successful
bid and a successful source of funding
what i'm wanting to do is to make sure
that we
think more broadly
about the nature of our local economy
and our social fabric and how to build
more resilience into our community going
forward and support and strengthen our
communities use our powers our
procurement our partnerships uh and our
investment for the district and this is
what i the basis of the the ideas that
are put forward in the liberal democrat
budget come from is to try to strengthen
and make sure that the small businesses
of this district the communities of this
district the residents of the this
district are the ones that are served by
this council and that's the basis of why
i put we put forward those ideas
now i i get you know i know that you
know that you're you are inclined not to
accept them and i am very grateful that
one of them was accepted but that's the
that's the role of us as opposition is
to raise the ideas to challenge you and
to make sure
thank you councillor curtis
thank you chair um
i apologize if uh council harvey is
irritated by our proposals
but as council juniors has just said
it should be the job
of an opposition group to scrutinize and
make alternative proposals that's why we
are here
firstly members will recall
that i thanked the section 151 officer
for his help
in making sure that our proposals still
resulted
in a balanced and robust budget with
sufficient reserves
i'm sure it's not council harvard's
intention
to criticize the judgment of our 151
officer that would be most inappropriate
secondly regarding earmarked reserves we
should be looking at these earmarked
reserves
in particular
i'm sure
all members in this room will be aware
of the 200 000 pound earmarked economic
recovery reserve but it's sitting there
to be spent over the next four years
why couldn't we look at bringing some of
that spend forward and spending it in a
way that the liberal democrats have
proposed thank you chair
thank you councillor rock
thank you chairman
um
just a couple of somebody's leaving i
was just about to target
i'll leave it for a bit
uh
councillor harvey i i i think it's
unfortunately used the word resentful
because he and i have a number of
conversations but i didn't i didn't feel
that he was resentful about things and i
think we've had some constructive
conversations um i i think
i i will i will mention councillor
pemberton uh the things that he said
these are matters of judgment and as my
colleague has just said
it is a balanced budget
mr snow has confirmed all that
it is a matter of judgment we we i think
we all agree that the objectives that
we're trying to achieve in the lib dem
budget are probably worthy there's a
different way of achieving it we have
different views between us uh and as uh
council junior just said it's our job as
opposition to scrutinize these things
and uh i'm i'm
i sort of slightly
i've got a lot of respect for cancer
harvey but it's unfortunate to use that
word i think but however there we are um
if i can refer to some other things that
have been said um council foreign
kindly pointed out that this the things
we've got in here do refer to the whole
of the district
now
it's a gentleman over here who is my my
neighbouring uh
neighbouring water council of bromwich
um
my house my plot of land has got an
association with a gunpowder plot that
was mentioned by councillor perchaguella
you we could exploit more things there
there's some fantastic heritage
buildings inside them and we don't make
enough of the tourism opportunities
there and i think we could do more for
that and i think that's why that is in
these proposals
the reason we've done some of these
things is all about leverage
so some of these things that we're
talking about with with the
certainly tourism is one but with the
community fund
if we can help village halls and those
sort of bodies community bodies we don't
need
to give them a lot for them to get more
from elsewhere and grant so it's a
question of getting more bangs for your
buck if i can use dreadful americanisms
um
councillor crump and myself i've tried
to get a cycle track between napton and
santan
which wants some work doing we can't get
a cycle track because the
the county council say they're only
going to support urban and inter-urban
cycle tracks we can't even get it off
the ground we just need a bit of help to
get that investigated that would help
councillor promise i suggest so it's
things like that i'd also mentioned
about shot mobility my mother-in-law is
a customer of shot mobility but she uses
the one that's geographically better
from our colleagues in warwick i hope
they're not listening because we're
using their resources instead of ours
but
let's hope we can put we can support one
another collectively on those things
and just finally i'll just make one
point and i will say something positive
about council of pemberton also because
he and i've had some
some positive conversations about the
self-build register uh and we are hoping
to get a working group together in one
way or another if we can make the
council systems work um but i just would
point out
um that what other councils do in terms
of this is a small amount in money terms
but would be beneficial in terms of
helping us manage a particular activity
um
other authorities part which is in
hertfordshire
they charge 125 quid to go on the
register
uh and uh what we've got some other ones
here cotswold charged 50 quid a year to
go on it so there is some scope there
for not only
controlling and influencing what we do
but raising a bit of evidence a finance
to cover the activities of some of our
councils that work in very hard
so
thank you for listening but those are
some points that i make and thank you
for your contributions
counselor up can i go now please
councillor howard
thank you councillor harris thank you
chair
good afternoon everyone it's nice to see
everyone back in the room
and hear the debate that's gone on
before us
i have to say agree with some of the
points and i don't agree with some of
the points as you can gather
as for the vulnerable and needy in my
communities
and those with disabilities most of them
can't afford to get out to use shop
mobility and the net zero doesn't really
hit on their radar
so i don't think a whole much way over
those um
schemes to be revisited in the budget
amendments
that said the community zero carbon fund
i advise look at schemes like the harvey
energy initiative
they give an alternative way of
highlighting and utilizing not these
schemes such as battery storage energy
saving electrical vehicle charging
points
self-provision from a group in the
community itself it's not responsibility
of this district council
i think we should expect more from our
communities and parishes but that
doesn't mean it should be from our
pockets
um it is a discretionary thing i think
council harvey touched on
and eventually i think i see a lot of
our discretionary
commitments will disappear
councillor junaid alluded to the
government in power i don't think it's
the government in power at fault here i
think what is it fault and i think
things are going to get worse as we go
forward is the way we govern
how we do government down in westminster
how they decide their policies and
legislation whether it be the
conservatives the lib dems or a another
until we actually change the mechanisms
down in parliament
for how things are funded in our
communities i see our public sector
getting more saturated
overwhelmed with work us getting less
money
and we need a conversation about
population growth none of these seem to
be on the agenda i have to say i can
care
with councillor bromwich's view we need
to sit down and really start talking
about this this because it's going to
get worse not better and we might debate
oh that's a good idea this is a good
idea but i think overall the end of the
day we're not going to have any money to
go around to do what we want to do we
all have a commitment to protect the
most vulnerable in our society
but at the moment the system's failing
us until we wake up and reform it and
reform it soon i think we're in trouble
thank you chair
thank you councillor jennings
thank you
well the vic's been mentioned a lot
um
the world's changed we need to change
and the vic possibly needs to change as
well
and we've got a year to look at it and
revisit it and there are all sorts of
options available there there's
relocation
there's something more high-tech or
indeed there may be just to remain the
same
but the effects are on tourism then it's
not 300 million or possibly up to 400
million off the local economy
the most common question asked at the at
the vic was
where the toilets
and the second one was which pubs can i
take the dog to
if the lib dems great idea to recover
this 400 million
is to keep that open
they're looking in completely the wrong
way
what we're what we're suggesting is that
we invest in the professionals who are
shakespeare's england
to look
to go and explore other options to see
what we can do
and to look at a broader district-wide
initiatives
thank you castle wallihawk organs
thank you
and i just want to go back to the self
building custom build housing register
because actually i know that the
officers of this council are actually
working very closely central government
at the moment because there are some
anomalies with the self-build and
custom-built housing register in that if
you have a self-built house then you
don't have to pay any sale money or any
section 106 monies
um there is legislation coming down the
line uh it's expected
shortly but not soon
um there are the the um parish of
halford has got a development proposal
for i think between eight and ten houses
on a site there they will not the
developers there that would be marketing
the self-building custom buildings
custom-built properties won't have to
pay any sale monies they're actually
penny section 106 monies the community
in short will not have to benefit from
that at all
and that is really fundamentally wrong
it goes back to what the lib dems are
proposing here that you know we all need
to be able to help village halls they've
all they've all had you know
all they've all suffered from lack of
footfall etc so actually i think we do
actually need to recognize that this
council and its officers are working and
i know that i'm looking at our um
mr bitter that you have also have this
in in your in your in your in your ward
i think we do have to um
act with caution over the self build and
also recognize the hard work that is
going in towards ensuring that there is
fairness and parity between four
contributions to to parishes you know
it's a small sums of money that can make
all the difference between doing to
doing those grants so i just wanted to
just make that point really um that you
know
that we are you know we are making
strides and we are looking at this
because that is quite a high number of
self builds here but we must also ensure
that the self build register isn't a way
forward of getting areas of the land
where permission wouldn't normally be um
granted that that that is given a a big
a big tick and i'm seeing that uh
darren pemberton is is not there that
that is the case it's really serious you
know and we're all looking at it i
believe that the sense that there is a
stalling going on now with regards to
these permissions and i applaud this
council its officers for for doing that
i think it's you know really really um
laudable that we are taking such an
active role with central government over
this i'd also like to say because you
know i'm one of on on my own here that
it's clear from the continued one-year
settlements that we are getting
that um
reorganization is coming of local
councils and on that note i shall sit
down thank you
thank you councillor fielding
thank you chair
um because of
conflict of interest i've been asked to
do
work with um some climate change um
sorry self-built properties and two
villages not in my ward
i'm appalled by the way that
the company's concerned a sort of
cavaliering approach to
self-built they are putting in or
basically taken over large areas
they haven't thought through the problem
with drainage
and consequently chairman
i'm sorry to can't cancel people now but
we we aren't debating the budget
proposals at the moment and not the
general approach to self-built
properties so this is to do with the
self-bell register
if it's relating to the budget
you like to continue fielding council
fielding is that finished
sorry would you like to continue
thank you
um
consequently the
the effect is on
not getting the sill payments
and because they've got to get highways
to work on it it is creating a
win-win for the developer i think that
we've got to do something better with
regards to self-built we've got to look
at it in a proper fashion and if the 50
quid or more is
going to come forward i think we we need
to look at that seriously
thank you councillor cargill
thank you chair
pick a few words out from the debate
which should be quite interesting hasn't
it it's been flowing backwards and
forwards and we've heard quite a few
different uh words and expressions
one was laudable the goals
of the
amendment
are laudable
but perhaps this is a philosophical
philosophical difference between us on
the side of the fence anyway
we look for more accountability to spend
money a business case
and it's not to the exclusion of our
residents at all in fact it's the
opposite it's how we can best spend our
money for our residents we haven't got
the money we can't spend it
if we said we can only spend a pound
once it's true
we only have that money once we've given
this money by our rhythms may not like
giving it to us but they do give it to
us
so
it comes down to balance and which way
we want to spend that money
now sadly as i say it's all down to
money i've mentioned money multiple
times why
where we are
this is this is what it is it's all
about how we spend the money
so with the limited resources
it's the best way we can spend it and as
i said that's a balance that's how we
decide what you decide on the week but
you're spending
for me i've gone through this with the
with the portfolio holder with the
section 151 offices
and the cabinet and the leader and we've
gone through this multiple times and
this in my view our budget is the way
forward
sadly i can't support the amendment
laudable though they are
i believe that we we should reject this
and we should stick with the budget that
has been put forward to this council
thank you
thank you castle junit
yes just to um uh just to
assure everybody that we did take advice
on the finances the sources of our
funding will leave nearly 100.8 million
for potential future capital projects
including the 0.5 million proposed to be
allocated for ict alignment across
stratford warwick and warwick we we know
we were not profligate we we have
actually looked at it
we also we know we can't account for it
we can't put it into our budget now but
we do want to report back from it
because we do know that there is a bill
into government
for a hundred thousand
pounds plus
for parking fund uh parking refund now
we can't count it as now but we know the
bill has gone into government we assume
that government will pay a bill that has
been presented to them which they have
said with they will cover for 75 of the
lost charges for for car parking
and we would like to know when that
money does come in that it actually has
come in and has not been you know used
for other purposes so we we did take we
took uh took sound advice
and just to pick up on one very other
one other small point that was raised
about the visitor information center
what we said we wanted was a fresh
vision we're not saying necessarily
we're only sticking to the one building
or whatever we want a fresh vision but
we want a a a
a
an information center that could
potentially actually offer far more
so we we just to be sure that we know we
we're open to ideas
and finally on the um the register i
welcome the fact that that is being
looked at and i also welcome the fact
that as chairman deputy uh chair of the
overview and scrutiny committee there is
going to be on the agenda in march a
proper look at the whole of the self
build and um community and
sets a whole self-built policy of this
council with an idea to be able to
recommend any changes that would be
beneficial
thank you councillor crump
thank you uh mr jim um i think um
catch the rock has been spending too
much time with me recently um
because he's doing some a lot more puns
in his speeches whether advertents or
inadvertent
um there was one about getting the cycle
path up off the ground i've got this
vision of flying cycles machine sathum
and
sethum and nuptum and they spoke about
the gunpowder plot and then he wanted
more bang for his book and i was
thinking
i think i had to give him a rocket for
that but um
but but seriously um
shot mobility
and again we've touched on this and
again i was listening to councillor rock
because his mother-in-law lives really
close to me and she's a pretty nice lady
now i've seen her light on a
but it's interesting that counts rock
mother-in-law is actually gone to use
the one in warwick what district because
it's far closer to us out in the east
well the far east is it's known
and i think this is where we've got the
opportunity to do things differently to
work smarter not harder and that's
whatever again the council let's get
more bang for our book so there's
opportunities to meet the same amount of
people or even enhance the amount of
people we do by working differently and
let's let's do things differently the
pandemic has really
changed the way we do things a lot more
things are being done online we're
having virtual meetings still
for when it's not a full council or
committee so we can do things
differently
things that we used to do are not always
the same and
i know
some councils yeah we're quite lucky
quite a few officers have come back here
and the officers are quite but other
councils um
the staff are just running around an
empty building so there's opportunity to
do things differently do we need to have
buildings for these different things or
do we need a smaller building or do we
need what have they called pop-up
buildings or whatever record these days
because we have pop-up everywhere we
have pop-up beer gardens we have pop-up
pubs so why can't we have a pop-up
council offers
especially in saigon where the new with
the new hq is going to be built for the
for the new super council and that would
help us in the east give us a um you
know obviously we're getting a lot more
support if you can get more support in
the east
from our uh tourism from our business
people from our grants people that would
be helpful and and that would be keep us
going until we got that economic boost
of that new hqb being built in sunny
southbound so i i do think there's
opportunities for us
um you know seriously but clemson at one
point cancer center made and there's no
such thing as a war in the game just
isn't that you know
you know cancer junior gave me a point
here they're on about the parking and uh
and i mentioned that the other day that
somebody complimented me on the parking
the other day because they left a note
on the windscreen it said parking fine
but
but seriously um
i think we have got
we do need to grow capacity
in our towns and parishes
and i think that was a good point that
council shenton made because we see some
patches um i know napton is great for
environmental issues neat uh harvard
were there green green travel green
wheels
bob sherman his climate team excellent
and the scene is an example nationally
but other communities are not haven't
got that capacity so as a council i
think we should be depend equality
fairness giving everybody the
opportunity to apply for these grants
because that hundred thousand pounds if
it was put in that would be gone just
like that it'd be quicker than my wife
spent in my year housekeeping
so it was you know
unbelievable
i can see some points but let's grab the
capacity let's give people a level
playing field and do a bit of a around
district council leveling off of
capacity level enough i wonder where
that's happened before
so let's let's do that let's let's walk
before we run let's get the capacity
there let's give people the
opportunities and ideas and also assist
them to bid for external funding because
there is still external funding around
and i think we do need to do both from
the capacity point of view and
a climate point of view but there's also
ones from things like mental health or
sporting clubs to get them to bid for uh
things from um i think wren and
recycling companies like that so let's
give them the opportunity to do it we we
provide the tools and they go and do the
job again providing the tools i'm sure
that's somebody famous mentioned that
somewhere but i can't remember who that
was
um somebody with a cigar i think so
whilst i think there are some good
points in lib them ones and you know we
have taken some on board and it was the
same um at the county we haven't got a
mutual a monopoly on good ideas and i
think it's fair that the dems do
challenge us
but ultimately we are accountable we
make the finals decision because we've
got the majority but let's speak let's
take them all on board
and i commend the budget as raised and
support councillor harvey because those
grumpy ones we need to stick together
don't be afraid to the hollywood
thank you thank you councillor ian
bradley
uh
thank you chair um
if i if i pick on a particular
subject say shop mobility
uh which the council is agreeing that
it's going to support
in this coming year
um
well the year is a year and this time
next year we might be emerged uh
council with with warwick
so in a year's time who would be making
the decision about
shot mobility
going forward
uh would it be this council or would it
be a merged council
thank you
great thank you i believe we haven't got
any more speakers so now
we will move to the votes on the
amendment uh consequently asks council
june ed is it okay to vote for this on
block or would you prefer individual
items
can i can i please note that uh the 50
000 pounds for the financial and energy
advice has been taken on board
and um happy for that to be um
that to be included but uh i would like
the rest to be looked at on block please
thank you
uh now invite david brooklyn to do the
votes
thank you chairman as chairman mentioned
earlier all decisions in relation to the
budget we we do need a recorded vote so
we are
considering the recommend the amendments
the recommendations which are on the
yellow paper um items one through to 1.4
on block they've been duly proposed and
seconded and and debated
i'll be calling your your name one at a
time and i'm asking whether please you
could indicate whether you are for
against or abstaining in relation to the
amendments is everybody clear on that
before i move to the vote
cool thank you so i'll start with
chairman of council councillor fitter
against
thank you
councillor dixon against
thank you councillor adam
four
the cue councillor [ __ ] four
thank you councillor barker against
you councillor bromwich against
thank you councillor cargill
thank against councillor crump
thank you
uh councillor curtis four
okay councillor eden
thank you councillor fielding
against
thank you uh councillor fleming
against
thank you council of feutic
four
thank you councillor foreman
against
thank you councillor ian frenchly
thank you councillor jenny frenchly
thank you councillor jackie harris
against
thank you councillor harvey
thank you councillor jefferson against
thank you councillor jennings
against
thank you councillor junaid
thank you councillor kendall against
thank you councillor kettle
against
thank you councillor mills
against
thank you council pemberton
thank you councillor pataguella
four
thank you councillor riley
for
thank you councillor rock for
thank you counselor shenton
against
thank you and councillor wally hoggins
against
thank you
chairman i make that 11 votes for
and 19 votes against therefore that is
lost thank you thank you so moving back
to the original budget proposed by
council harvey and seconded by
councillor cargill do you have any
further
comments
no okay so um we will now move to the
votes please so i'll now invite daddy
buckland to take
a named vote
thank you chairman um so we are now
considering
the item 8 the the the white paper the
set of recommendations that came through
from the cabinet which were earlier
proposed and seconded
again i will be asking whether you are
for against or abstaining
in relation to the budget proposals as
presented
sorry
i've got some whispering going on on my
left hand side then i'll start with
chairman of council council officer for
thank you uh councillor dixon
uh councillor dixon four thank you
councillor adam
councillor i don't know abstain
thank you councillor [ __ ]
abstain
thank you councillor barker paul
thank you councillor bomage
boar
thank you councillor cargill for
thank you councillor crump
thank you councillor curtis
thank you councillor eden abstain
thank you councillor fielding paul
thank you
councillor fleming
for
thank you councillor foytec abstain
thank you council of foreman
oh
thank you councillor ian presley
thank you councillor jenny freshly
thank you jackie harris
oh
thank you councillor harvey
thank you councillor jefferson
oh
thank you council jennings paul
thank you councillor tune it
pemberton
thank you councillor patrick
abstain
thank you counselor riley
abstain
thank you counselor what
abstain
thank you um councillor shenton for
councillor woolly hoggins
oh
thank you
thank you just the way that we've been
going for nearly two hours would anyone
like a quick break seeing some nod so
yeah we'll take a 10 minute german thank
you
right so meeting is now resumes uh
moving on to
where are we
item nine um treasury management
strategy statement and the annual
investment strategy first wednesday 22
2023 23 please
uh invite councillor harvey to introduce
this report
thank you mr chairman
this is an annual requirement under the
guidance issued by the department for
leveling up housing and communities
for councils to draw up and approve an
annual investment strategy that meets
the chartered institute of public
finance and accountancy's treasury
management code of practice
this council's proposed treasury
management strategy for the fourth
coming year is set out in pages 81 to
117
that comprise appendix one of the paper
considered by the council by the cabinet
at its meeting on the 9th of february
2022
at that meeting i drew attention
to the i drew it to the attention of
members of the cabinet just one of the
aspects of the papers considered the
expectation for investment returns in
the immediate future to remain low
that said
we've now seen two rises in consecutive
months in bank rates to 0.5 percent
the first time this has happened since
2004
the bank of england has serious concerns
about its ability to control inflation
in current circumstances through
monetary policy
interest rates are anticipated to
continue to rise during 2022 albeit by
modest levels
by historic standards with consequences
for the borrowing costs of both
individuals
and those of the government itself
whilst there's the prospect of a rise in
the council's investment returns in 2022
their scale remains both uncertain and
modest the proposed capital and
investment strategy for the period 20 22
23 to 25 26 was set out in appendix 2 on
a pages 119 to 127 of the papers also
considered on the 7th of february
that proposal provided the framework
within which it's intended the council
should make its capital and investment
decisions over the next five years
on the assumption that councillors have
been able to familiarize themselves with
these papers and subject to any
questions they may have i ask that
approval is given to recommendations one
to four as set out in the paper now
before the council
thank you mr chairman
thank you and i'll look for a seconder
councillor shenson accounts to junaid
um just just um a question um i it came
to my notice uh the other day um from
the
local government association uh that
they have an investment uh fund and i
just want is that something that this
district council um invests in and
perhaps if you haven't got an answer
today maybe an uncertain later stage
i'll gladly answer that later stage when
i have the information available thank
you for the question
any further questions
no okay then so um
um
i believe that's agreed as i agreed
everyone
thank you uh item 10 the prudential
indicators please invite counselor
harvey to introduce this report
in conjunction with considering its
budget for the forthcoming year the
council is required by the chartered
institute of public finance and
accountancy's prudential code to set
prudential indicators that ensure that
its capital investment plans are
affordable prudent and sustainable
the report considered by by the cabinet
on the 7th of february took account of
the council's decision to borrow up to
15.6 million pounds to support the
delivery of the current capital program
the paper considered at that meeting set
out the factors that the council through
its section 151 officer is required to
take into account when considering the
affordability in its particular
circumstances of its intended capital
expenditure
over the period of the medium-term
financial strategy
and the affordability of capital
financing requirement to which the
intended expenditure may give rise
councillors will have noted the
intention to incur capital expenditure
in relation to the materials recycling
facility the council's share of
expenditure as a result of the new
refuse collection contract and in
relation to the facilities in the
district's leisure centers with the
relevant amounts being set out in
paragraphs 1.4 to 1.6 of the paper
considered on the 7th of february
the section 1-5 officer is able to
confirm that he continues to be
satisfied that the requirements of
paragraph 1.11
of the paper considered by the cabinet
on 7th february which identified the
indicators to which the council is
required to have regard would continue
to be observed
and met
councillors are asked therefore to
approve the recommendations set out in
the paper that the proposed prudential
indicators for the forthcoming year be
approved
thank you mr chairman thank you and i'll
seek a second
council of hampton thank you but anyone
would like to speak
on this no we in agreement
lovely thank you so item 11 um like to
inform everyone that the meeting uh that
in accordance with the local authorities
standing orders england the amendment uh
regulations 2014 that are recorded votes
will be taken on this council tax for
the uh 2022-23
uh please my invite councillor jefferson
as leader of the council to introduce
this item
thank you chair
this is to approve the formal council
tax resolution
uh as detailed in appendix
on this color paper
everyone having now set their presets
all the other precepting bodies having
done so
we've now got the total of the preset
required
for the coming financial year 2223
we have to approve these otherwise we
don't get any money so can i propose
that we
approve the formal council tax
resolution at appendix one please
thank you now seeker seconder council of
fielding
would anyone like to discuss this item
nope moving forward okay um just on the
vote if everyone can please turn on
their microphones and just wait a moment
before i'm speaking uh please
thank you chairman so we are voting now
on the move paper in relation to the as
the leader mentioned just then the
council tax resolution if you could
please when i call your name indicate
whether you are for against or
abstaining for that uh recommendation
i'll start with chairman of council
councillor fitter
for
thank you councillor dixon
casa dixon four
thank you councillor adam um abstain
councillor alcock
abstain
councillor barker boar
thank you councillor bromwich paul
thank you councillor cargill paul
um councillor crump guides the grant for
thank you
councillor curtis
is absent um councillor eden
abstain
thank you councillor fielding
for
thank you councillor fleming
or
councillor feuertech paul
thank you council of foreman four
thank you councillor ian frenchly
abstain
um councillor jenny freshly
thank you councillor harris
oh
thank you councillor harvey
four
thank you councillor jefferson four
thank you councillor jennings four
thank you councillor junit council of
genetic abstain
okay
uh councillor kendall four
thank you councillor kettle
four
thank you councillor mills
thank you
um
counselor pemberton
for
thank you kenzie bertigiella abstain
thank you councillor riley
captain riley four
thank you
councilman rock
abstain
thank you councillor shenton
paul
thank you and councillor wally hoggins
four thank you
chairman i'll make that 21 votes for
with eight abstentions therefore it's
carrying thank you
great thank you
uh item 12 minute 421 the adoption of
revised enforcement policy and business
charter please my invite councillor
kettle uh to introduce this report
thank you mr chairman
um
this is an administrative
thank you castlevan um ladies and
gentlemen this is this is not a a
groundbreaking breaking um
paper this is to reflect
um in terms of uh licensing
environmental health and a number of
other
regulated areas
um
the
changes in legislation on which our
enforcement policy is based
um i do of course exclude planning
enforcement which is not part of my
portfolio which is current covered by
councillor parry who regrettably is not
here today
um but in terms of the bits that cover
my portfolio it is really just
reflecting legislative changes have
taken place with
uh businesses
and to negotiate where there are hiccups
rather than
um it's not the sledgehammer to crack a
nut approach
um clearly those who are one or two
people who may consider enforcement is
something which they can treat
with um
uh or disregard and clearly we do have
the sanction in law
to take formal action in those cases but
our policy will continue to be as it
always has been
to work with the businesses in this in
this district
um to ensure they are able to comply
with the law and do comply with the law
mainly well to protect our residents and
those
individuals who are making use of those
services
um the one introduction is the business
charter
and this is a document the warwick
district council have used in the past
uh and this business charter that we're
introducing reflects that in warwick
which really just sets out the
relationship between us as the local
authority and businesses in our district
as to how we can help and support those
businesses
uh carry out their activities um in
compliance with whatever legislative uh
framework which are responsible
uh i commend um
this to all members i don't think
there's anything controversial in
anything that i'm proposing today and
would would hopefully get your support
for it
thank you uh please my secret secondary
council um mills council rock
thank you chairman um
i've i've no wish to uh
put the portfolio holder on the spot
with elements that may not concern his
portfolio
however
a suggestion that it may not become
controversial
may turn out to be uh
not quite accurate
firstly
this is the document you're about to
approve should you do so
it's 44 pages and um
it was went through the camera i think
in december
uh and i just wonder how many people are
familiar with it they're about to vote
upon it
not many i suspect
um now what intrigues me is that for
instance a substantial part of this and
again i i i
don't want to put counter kettle on the
spot but a substantial part of this is
the our enforcement policy and our
enforcement process now we spent a lot
of time with this on the regulatory
committee
um
i gather this was looked at by the
cabinet and and by the scrutiny
committee which seems a bit of an odd
process to me either it falls under the
purview of the
regulatory committee or the scrutiny
committee i don't quite understand
what's happened
uh it says in here
in section 1.5
it replaces the
planet enforcement policy
that was already been proved by the
regulatory committee so that implies
it's different
now council and military committee spent
a lot of time looking at that one is it
different can somebody tell us if it's
different and i'm sure i don't i guess i
don't put cancer kettle on the spot so
that's the first point
then on section 4.3 it says when it
appropriate they will share data with
other
authorities now is there a gdpr
implication of that
and and finally uh and i'm just picking
examples that i looked at before this
meeting
uh in 3.1 it says this this will apply
to various um
various
investigations including for instance
dog control and uh
and fouling
then it goes on to say any person
suspected of committing an offence will
be invited to an attended interview
under caution
in accordance with the police and
criminal evidence act
now i'm sure that's not what it means
but that's what it says
um so there are details in here
that to my minds one want a closer
examination than we can actually do in
full council now i don't know how the
best way of dealing with this is but i'm
not actually terribly happy
with approving that at council in the
way we are asked to do there may be
other things in here i may have
misunderstood all this i'm happy to be
corrected but uh i look for advice on
what we should do but i think when a big
document like this
and trying to do it now is uh
i'm not quite sure what the proper way
forward is thank you very much chairman
um thank you councillor perhaps i could
just
take you to paragraph 4.1
of the cabinet papers of um in december
explanation of the approach to dealing
with non-compliance the general
principle will always hinge around
negotiation advice guidance education
support to ensure maximum benefit from
the minimum resource input
aiming to avoid imposing unnecessary
regulatory burdens
enforcement procedures will always
follow statutory requirements and
guidance
whilst court proceedings include
prosecution will normally be directed
towards those who deliberately fail to
comply there will also be occasion when
proceeding is deemed to be appropriate
in certain other circumstances
uh we will clearly explain the not
compliance the actions required or
decision taken with the reasons for
these
we'll provide those who are subject to
enforcement action with an opportunity
for dialogue in relation to the advice
given actions required or decisions
taken in relation to non-compliance
so the whole onus of this paper
is to work with
not um
as a negotiated way forward it is not
um
to to use this as a weapon to drag
people in front of uh whatever authority
is necessary uh that is the way this
council wants to work forward with
enforcement
and i'm coaching from the paper itself
thank you just like to invite uh phil
grafton to speak
um just to um address councillor rock's
point about process
so
the way that um this works is that
documents which are either part of the
budgetary framework or in this case the
policy framework are ultimately the
decision of
counsel
council
there is a list within the constitution
of
some of those documents
but that part of the constitution also
says that documents that have
traditionally been accepted as as
council policy but are not listed shall
also be treated that way so the first
point i would make is if council is
prepared to
endorse adopt this policy today then i
would be asking for
a recommendation to be accepted as well
that
i as monitoring officers are given
authority to
include it within that list
in terms of the
regulatory committee
you've already mentioned the fact that
it's gone through cabinet and it had
overview and scrutiny committee look at
it as well
i think you've got a good point about
the involvement of regulatory committee
although they wouldn't have been making
decisions about the document
i think with hindsight we can learn a
lesson from this and perhaps make sure
that we pick that up later on in terms
of the technicalities of the document
and whether it is a fresh one or adopted
i'm going to pass over to the chief
executive to explain that thank you
okay i think what the enforcement
document does is it refreshes certain
parts and it consolidates others which
have been previously debated so
this policy
um in instead helping the council set
policy that it has been debated properly
within the kavanaugh it was then debated
within the um
osc and it's here for approval today i
will say all of the papers for all of
the committees
all members of council receive
communications to say when paper's been
published
it is the responsibility of of council
members really to appraise themselves of
the documents which are coming forward
to council for consideration so
you we we we can provide the information
to you obviously but we can't enforce
you to to read every page uh counselor
of every single document that comes for
but content that this afternoon you you
could make a decision in relation to
this this policy thank you thanks
council brothers
yeah just get started declaration of
interest because i hold a dual private
hire hackney license because um council
rock and brought up her about being
interviewed under caution
i've actually had that experience prior
to my council days my predecessor on my
seat
so actually
what the process is council rock is this
regard it obviously was relevant to a
criminal investigation as well as a
licensing breach at the time so we are
actually you are actually into under
course and because that can be used in
evidence against you or against the
party that was involved at that
particular point in time and i think
it's very clear the officers do do their
job properly and that has to be part of
the process that on certain
circumstances that when you are
interviewed sometimes it's under caution
and it's perfectly within the law it's
from actually do i can't remember the
exact bit style but i remember it all
being read out to me and very ably
recorded at this particular point in
time
thank you councillor junit
just to clarify a little bit um about uh
planning enforcement and why we feel
very strongly about it
this group actually did put forward a a
fully thought out
very considered document to the
consultation on planning enforcement
and we were actually had afterwards um
the cpr
cpre got in touch with us and actually
praised us for our input into that
consultation
uh and the judgment that we made it on
it we also sent in uh our thoughts on
that to the government
because we felt that the planning
enforcement laws at a government level
were
incredibly weak and therefore it does
make it more difficult for a council
such as ourselves
to to
you know enforce
uh and um
just on a technicality we actually had
uh councillor parry before the overview
and scrutiny committee and did put an
enormous amount of questions to her we
had a a prolonged session with her and
with most of that uh did uh did focus on
planning enforcement
the actual paper didn't come to obvious
scrutiny committee on our agenda it came
as do we want to make any comment on
anything that was going to cabinet
so really the the oh the overview
and scrutiny part of it was the
questions we put to the cabinet member
i really do feel that a lot of those a
lot of our input and a lot of the
questions we raised
would not have not been properly um
encompassed into this final document
and i would urge that we we know that um
maybe you you start with this one but
that we do consider why
uh so many people i do have problems
with uh with with planning enforcement
and they are considerable a number of
people so
just to illustrate
uh i've had an a an issue in my town i
don't know whether you know hopefully
you know but the three tons in ulster
burnt down 10 months ago
and
we did get in touch i got in touch with
the planning enforcement to see what
could be done to make sure
that everybody you know that was
involved
was
encouraged and supported
and then maybe urged to get some action
done initially for a tin hat to protect
the building early on
and then for other action
i was told informally
that i should not ask for formal action
because formal action would cost the
council money
and that is this had to be done through
negotiation only with the landowners and
insurance
ten months on
we now only a week ago actually had the
construction engineers on site to tell
us and what could be done with that one
would be done with that building this is
a grade two listed building
so you know i'm just
just saying that this is a whole
community that wanted action taken or
wanted something uh you know to to make
sure that something was done
and it's taken 10 months to get to this
stage
so we we do need to be be aware of the
powers that this council has and make
sure that they are are utilized so it's
not a matter of taking just a light
touch it's actually a matter of taking
uh where it is really crucial we should
be taking action
and you know we
we did put a lot of that not the
individual case but a lot of other
things to the um cabinet member
and um
we just feel that a lot of the
suggestions we made a lot of the
questions we asked a lot of the
consultation that we took trouble to
write put into writing have actually not
been taken seriously and taken on board
uh so you know we
we we know we know the in national
legislation is incredibly weak
but we wanted to make sure that this
council could hold its head up and and
on what it could and would be able to do
uh within the within the council within
it within the resources we have we were
not asking for help but we've not put
that into our own into our budget for
extruder it's just how we use them more
sensibly so um i do hope that um going
forward those comments will be taken on
board
thank you councillor purzukila
yes so i
i really want to um
echo council junaid's words so cancer
cattle if i understood correctly is that
this the new thrust
of this enforcement policy
is that we we move towards negotiation
well i have an example of how
negotiation failed in my world where the
developers in a new development cut down
all the trees um
they cut down all the trees that should
have been retained they cut down the
native hedgerow they should have been
retained they
the council did not open an enforcement
case but they negotiated
uh they asked
for revised plans to be submitted which
they did the revised plans did not
meet uh the requirements of of the
council of our own uh you know uh
forestry officer and they were asked to
do it again now that's that was three
years ago
now residents who have occupied these
houses are we are left with a mess so
i'm sorry but you know when we need to
take action we need to take action
thank you
thank you council kettle councillor
peter keller thank you for that comment
but as i did um explain as i started out
planning enforcement is not part of my
portfolio so regrettably i'm not in a
position to respond
to the points you've raised which i can
understand would be of concern
what i would say is in terms of those
areas which i is covered by my portfolio
um
the i will quote the incidence of
non-compliance no i've lost it um are
revealed voluntary and there's a
willingness to resolve
uh the issue the council will provide
support and seek to avoid the need for
formal enforcement action that is in
relation to those
individuals who are not in compliance
with our current policies and are not
talking about
planning enforcement i'm talking about
the other areas uh which council are
referred to
and social behavior environmental
protection food safety health and safety
licensing all those areas we do try to
work with businesses
so um i'm not in a position to answer
about the planning enforcement issue
you've raised i'm sure uh had my
colleague been here she'd respond may i
suggest that you put a a question in
writing to her
uh and then
the answer can be come from her directly
thanks phil's going to add a couple of
comments
um just just to remind members as part
of this debate that if you do want to
provide any examples please please keep
them anonymized and i'm not suggesting
that anyone has at the moment
um given details sufficient for people
to identify which planning enforcement
issue they're on about but if if you
could just make sure you keep it
completely
anonymised please thank you
thank you tony burks do you have a
comment
uh yes thank you chairman if i could
just perhaps try and help council here
the amendment for the polit for the
policy tries to pick up two things in
the main it's really trying to implement
sort of updated government guidance on
how we should sort of work with
businesses and our regulatory function
to support them in complying with their
duties in sort of an economic recovery
type mold
the planning enforcement section is
dealt with separately there is an
appendix to the um
the policy which deals specifically with
planning enforcement in stratford and it
may be some comforts accounts just unit
and pertiguella that both of the
instances that they cited which is work
to a listed building or sort of ongoing
works with trees and conservation areas
or tpo trees are both in the critical
category which would give its highest
level of planning enforcement attention
so i think those points are both sort of
covered within the policy so i hope that
was helpful to you
thank you councillor harris thank you
chair
i noted all the points made i think
council jr does um strike a correct one
since i was elected in 2015 my concern
has been around enforcement
particularly
little action is taken and when we have
retrospective situations where people
have gone ahead rogue builders etc
gone ahead with planning without the
appropriate permissions we just rub a
stamp it and say yes which is to me is
rewarding
bad behaviour but more than that seems
to be again undermining local government
because we haven't got the funds
to carry out enforcement listening to
what's being said in the room today
which goes back to councillor harvey's
point is how do we spend the money
well i'd rather see the money go out to
sanctioning those who are abusing um our
authority and the um district
more so than some of the other things
that have been offered here today so
going forward i'd ask when we're setting
the budget that perhaps we consider more
money for enforcement to show that we
are a council to be reckoned with i
appreciate what mr perks has said about
there's a suite of different sanctions
and ways of taking things forward
including negotiation but the bottom
line is it's becoming a laughingstock
and we seem as easy pickings
thank you i think we've got points of
order from councillor rock
chairman i wanted to propose an
amendment if i may
sure is that an order
uh
it's just not my intention to hold up
the work of the council so we can get on
with things but um i'm proposing that a
review
this would be a third point on the on
the uh
on the recommendation
the review of the enforcement policy and
charter is added to the work plan of the
regulatory committee or such other
committees as is appropriate
this this to take place in the coming
year so
what i'm suggesting is that
some of these things are looked at in
the coming years so we can approve it
now and then we can re-examine it in
case
there are some of the points that i've
made earlier on so we can get on with it
but let's let's have a look at it in
future
uh council pemberson i'll look for a
second to chairman
thank you uh chair um that's the right
just in terms of trying to provide some
added clarity because in the coming year
can mean anything and i think one of the
things that
we need to consider is
uh in any review is how that policy is
working so i think if we were looking at
a review that said after the first 12
months of operation that would give some
clarity and certainty and some
runway to in to to have an evidence base
as to whether there is anything
demonstrably
um adverse about this approach which in
real terms is only reinforcing the
approach that we've all known that we've
had in that you know we look for you
know direct enforcement action as our
last rather than our first resort so for
example the notion of planning
applications to regularize things so i
think that if you were minded to have a
an amendment that talks about a review
after 12 months
i think that could probably find favor
if you're willing to accept that i'm
willing to second it
i i reason i'm hesitating i don't want
to prolong matters but the reason i'm
hesitating is i'm uncomfortable with
some of the words in this document
as they presently stand
um
and uh
i
i welcome that intervention
i i i just don't want to prolong it
because there are other things to do
with the coordination with warwick that
i think could well be looked at as well
however if that's what we've got to do
to get it forward i i will accept that
uh as a friendly amendment to the
amendment or whatever
whatever the rules are in the
debate first of all
um well i'll just ask phil crofton to
read out the amendment with this
added but
okay so so what we've got is um the
review of the enforcement
and the business case that business
charter policies be undertaken by the
regulatory committee and for this to
take place after 12 months of operation
other appropriate committees i think i
said because the business charter is
probably another committee chairman
sorry which one well i don't know
appropriate it may be if it if you
advise it's regulatory okay mr grafton
i'm sure that's fine of the appropriate
committee or committees
okay
thank you and a second up please
councillor pemberton
yeah is everyone in agreement
agreed
okay thank you so that's the
amendment accepted so now
um is everyone agreed with the so the uh
the original uh document
as well
you'll remember earlier i i did suggest
that you you might be um willing to have
a fourth
um
resolution which is to authorize me as
monitoring officer to include these two
policies that's the enforcement policy
and the business charter
within the constitution
as one of the council documents
is there a proposal for that please
counselor pemberton secondary councillor
council we in agreement
lovely thanks everyone
okay moving on to
item 13. we've got the local government
association councillor code of conduct
please invite councillor crump to
introduce this item
just to keep the stereotype going for
cancer center
another exciting issue
from from a from a foreign accountant
here
on pink as well so it's not even on gray
paper so
um
it's ordinary standards last week uh we
took uh talked about the local
government association council of code
conduct
um previously stratford district council
and us work district council had decided
to adopt this code of conduct
and therefore
the purpose of the meeting was to
seek adoption the lightest version of
the document
and also to have a
we felt it sensible that both councils
of common set of related principles
procedures a joint training program
again using our money better getting
more bang for our book and a single date
for bringing the two codes into
operation
and again to make it easier and and less
ambiguous all um
there would be some
guidance notes on this application and
examples in order to add counselors
kindly mr crafton arranged for external
training to provide training sessions on
the new code
uh and these sessions again will be
online uh available to district 10 and
paris councils
and also we were hoping to invite walk
as well because they we feel they've got
a role as well
um
the lga is is committed to actually
reviewing the code on an annual basis to
ensure it's still fit for the purpose
and
the community felt that was was fair and
reasonable
and any uh proposals would be considered
by mr grafton the monitoring officer and
brought to members as they consider
appropriate
and as part of alignment policy we would
also as part of a meeting um
talk about uh
compliance procedures which differed at
burst council so
um
we felt the the code uh the changes to
the code strengthened areas around about
bullying and vexatious behaviour which
was particularly welcome to the
community
and the actual recommendations are on
the pink
pink paper not the pink panther
which i nearly said just then so
uh
but uh so yeah um i'll recommend to the
council that uh
the the five proposals uh
recommendations
are agreed
thank you i seek a seconder uh
councillor harris thank you uh
councillor junior would you like to
speak uh just that i do note this and
actually welcome it particularly the
training bit uh i feel it's absolutely
crucial
if people are to have trust in their
local councillors and and local
democracy um that we are absolutely
solid about how we conduct our business
so um just that i welcome the training
uh and welcome the training particularly
on any declarations local interests etc
etc so welcome it and uh hope that that
happens fairly soon
thank you any further
points
there is everyone in agreement to move
awesome probably thank you
uh item 14 uh minute 565 the calendar of
meetings please my invite councillor
crump to again uh introduce this report
can get them value for money today two
for the price of one i'll buy one and
get one for free
i'm not sure you know the acronym for
that one uh again we discussed about the
calendar of meetings it makes sensible
to align committee dates with the
warwick council
and obviously the proposals are
mentioned in in the uh in the paper
uh quite self-explanatory um
we did touch on about uh
um
trying to encourage people a different
to apply to become counselors counselors
particularly
who working of child care issues or not
just child care caring issues i
apologize for the sites of the tonight
just carrying issues for people of all
ages
um so
we thought that was important that we
would look at start time of meetings be
revisited uh in in the near future
um
obviously we've got the meetings here
again pretty self-explanatory um
and again um
hopefully it's not too contentious i
said that this time last year and all of
a sudden it uh we had a whole raft of
questions about this and
hopefully um
audience standards committee uh sort of
like agreed and i can see kenzie barker
wanting to come and then
come on with something so just to be
awkward uh just to be challenging so um
thank you for that
thank you just comment i will lose a
week of being chairman but that's that's
fine
uh councillor parker
sorry just before that do we have a
second please
it council harris who comes to parker
um yes councillor crump um as a former
chairman of uh audit and standards i you
have my sympathy um but i do have just
one question can you tell me why
overview and scrutiny has been moved to
a friday
it's um we'll get
moving it to friday there's going to be
more time for over here in scrutiny to
actually look at the papers and uh
so it's going to be earlier so yeah they
will have more time um
and yeah it wouldn't quite yeah that was
a good question it was actually us at
the meeting as well so great minds
thinker likes whoever asked the question
at the meeting was
a great reminder you could say cancer
but yeah there were more times so good
better time for scrutiny thank you
they didn't take my i didn't ask me
okay uh councillor perticula
yeah sorry um i can't find the answer in
the papers but um
at times
at the time's been discussed so um for
example the full council meeting which
has been moved to a wednesdays have
times times of um does it stay at 2pm or
we go in the evening because obviously
times are deep
are quite important for inclusion and
yeah for inclusivity thank you
um
counselors may be aware that the actual
time of individual meetings is down to
the committee
um and not for counsel
um so
so those times will need to be
considered carefully
when each committee um then meets
thank you counselor
bromwich yeah i know with interest
councillor crump's comments about trying
to make um commit as inclusive as
possible in times that
which is quite strange because we have a
policy in this council if you don't
attend a certain number of meetings
you're able to have your allowance stop
it's all very fine if we time meetings
so for example someone like myself who
is currently
looking after two teenage boys
has to work as well to go with it
and then ends up on the regulatory
committee which is at half nine in a
friday morning where it's impossible to
attend due to work commitments which is
the choice of being self-employed
it does appear that we sort of almost
contradict ourselves and maybe we have
to start thinking about um how we are
going to encourage people on committees
and try and work on better timings for
people's lives we're never going to get
it perfect
but i think it's a bit unfair if we then
start punching people because
of their life
and care and what they have to do in
their lives does also end up punishing
them financially when they're actually
working really hard as counselors in
general anyway maybe something we have
to look at as a general point of view
thank you councillor for jerk
thank you chair yeah it's just really
just to find out
on the start time certainly of full
council meetings it's not for debate
today i understand that
but it would be useful for the committee
for auditing standards to actually
to actually find out what counsellor
preferences are
that would be quite useful
chairman thank you i i think i'd just
like to remind councillors that that
issue was raised i think it was about
two years ago now when we did then
canvas
all councillors we didn't really get to
a consensus about what would be the
preferable time with some prefer in the
morning some of the afternoon and some
of the evening and when when that method
mata came back to council at that
particular point it was resolved to stay
with the the two o'clock start time
i think councillors will also be aware
that the report that was approved by
both councils in december
in relation to the creation of the well
the submission for the southwestern
district council
did identify under section 4 that the
start time of meetings would be an issue
that would need to be dis discussed and
debated ahead of the the creation of the
new authority and the leaders actually
expressed a preference within that
particular report of both authorities
that
meetings should generally start in the
evening that that was a presumption of
the direction of travel but but for this
calendar of meeting for the next year
there wouldn't be any suggestion to move
away from two o'clock start time for the
council unless council so wished but but
that that that view and we can
recirculate the results of the
consultation i think you're the same
councillors to be honest
did that that that exercised it before
so we have been there council forward
thank you thanks councillor harris
thank you chair thank you mr buckland
unfortunately the ground has changed i
have to compare with councillor bromage
um full council is not as frequent as it
was it's made it hard for some of us who
are working full-time with caring
commitments to get here
i think our role should not just be
looked as attending meetings there's a
lot of hard work that's done
i know legally we're constrained in some
respects maybe we should have a closer
look at that of what we can do i think
initially the meetings were six and have
increased to eight
maybe revisit that or revisit the
punitive
way of
hurting councillors who genuinely can't
make it here and the other concern is if
we want it to come towards uh in front
of full council
obviously there's a process to get it on
the agenda
democratic services are doing their best
to note if anyone falls beneath the
cracks
but with the best will in the world the
amount of work this council's got at the
moment things will fall through the
cracks so we need something quicker or
ready for a dispensation
for a member who falls through the
cracks whether it's through caring ill
health work et cetera et cetera so it
does need revisiting thank you thanks
councilwoolcock
thank you chair yes um
i i do agree with with the booking in
meetings it can be very difficult when
you are working and you have children i
must admit i quite like this this one
part about the kind of meetings
that the exception of the february 2023
meeting which has remained on a monday
to avoid the half term
uh
chair i don't have those dates for half
term but i have children at primary
school high school and the college
and interestingly one of my slight
concerns with saying
a meeting has changed date due to school
holidays
even in warwickshire district as a whole
schools stagger their holidays
some children off last week
in warwickshire my children were off
this week
so um i completely understand what
council bombards you saying
it's very hard when you have a pet when
you are preparing for a child at school
your holidays that you can take as a
family are limited you can only take
those school holidays that are set
having a meeting in the middle of a
february half term
if that's when we are taking a holiday
as a family
it could be the only opportunity to take
a family but it could end up with a
counsellor being penalized for it
um
which does strike me as very unfair we
all work very very hard
um but i'm not too sure what the
solution is in this situation with
school holidays changing
and being staggered
i'm just wondering if there could
there's a little bit of a
of a flexibility that could be put on in
this sort of situation thank you or just
let councillor uh crumple respond
thank you mr chairman yeah we have been
talked about about this at the meeting
um
and sometimes you damned if you do
damned if you don't and you won't be
able to please all the people all the
time because i know that some people
who are
school teachers potentially wouldn't be
able to attend meetings in non-turn time
but when they're in um after holiday and
i'm about to come to a meeting
um so
it's a very difficult
what we're trying to say is we're trying
to be more sensitive we won't please all
the people all the time and whatever you
do
there will be somebody who won't be able
to attend but let's try and get all the
information from people let's see what
people can attend and when they can't
attend and then see what fits the best
you know um so we are trying to be more
sensitive
to to everybody because we do
with with one or two exceptions but
we're not in the first flushes of youth
here shall we say um i'll see you that
doesn't fall at you thanks a lot
uh
dude it's more on the radar though it
tends to be a lot more debates and we
did touch about the discipline
dispensations as well
at the last meeting as well so yeah we
think
this is the best of a bad job at the
moment i know it's it's not very easy to
say and things can improve and obviously
with the potential creation of the super
district there will be some initial pain
before we start to align them but once
last started to be more aligned it will
be definitely a lot easier for countries
and also for officers we need to take
that into account one the officers come
to prepare all the meetings and two
officers trying to be in different
places at once because i know mr grafton
managing officer came to audit standards
with me and then have to rush off to um
to warwick district then i hope you
didn't get your speeding ticket phil so
that server um but yeah we are trying to
be considerate we think you know things
do change and it's good we are getting
slightly younger members i cancel out
them um
but uh and can you catch the pizza sorry
you're far away because i can't see
about the classes um but yeah it's a
difficult one um so
can we just agree on this occasion the
recommendations
but with we did put a commitment it was
suggested that the start time meetings
be revisited in the new in that in the
near future so uh and also we'll be
looking at dispensations as well so um a
good debate it wasn't just a five minute
job talking about this and we did take
it seriously so and so yeah
the chair audit and standards i'm happy
it was debated for it
thank you before i invite councillor
pemberton and then councillor harvard to
speak and just just need to propose that
we
continue the meeting as it's approaching
through hours so i i propose that we
continue do i have a secondary
council pemberton all agreed
thank you council pemberton
yeah thank you chair um
members we're not going to get to a
landing on this we've got a set of
proposals in front of us i think the
chair of audit and standards and the
chief executive
have heard the debate and look around
and and you know the desire for some
flexibility and some clarity
particularly around for cancer so i
propose we move to the vote
okay thank you so i've got a uh
counselor harvard you wanted to speak
very quickly
yes very quickly i i realized that as
councillor krumper said whatever
calendar you come up with you won't
serve the interests of everybody and
everybody does want to make their full
commitment uh as participating on the
committees on which they serve i just
make the point that section 85 of the
1972 local government act
deals with a question of absence from
committees and you only cease to be a
councillor if you miss
six months meetings
over a period
on any committee so you can you can you
can attend a council meeting you can
attend a committee meeting you can
attend
a the meeting of a body upon which you
are have been nominated to serve on
behalf of the council
once in six months and you still retain
your position as a counselor so the the
bottom line is nobody's trying to im
to disqualify anybody
and there does come a point where
you have to be prepared as a counselor
to to put in
a certain amount of attendance in order
to justify your position in relation to
your to your residence so i just point
out section 85 read it it's quite
interesting
okay thank you do you have any
further questions comments no so we've
got proposer and seconder um is everyone
in agreement
lovely thanks thanks everyone
um
1915 minute 574 the joint appointments
committee please not invite counselor
jefferson to introduce this report
thank you chair
uh this is about considering interim
proposals to establish a joint
appointments committee for
stratford-on-avon and warwick district
councils
these proposals seek to provide a single
decision-making process to enable a
coordinated and consistent approach to
chief officer appointments
this has become particularly important
following the resignation of the head of
finance and it is urgent to bring
forward these proposals for the
appointment of senior roles within both
councils
it's proposed that the joint
appointments committee will be
politically balanced and comprise 12
councillors six from each authority
which will include both leaders
with the terms of reference set out in
the document
the main function of the joint
appointments committee
will be to recruit the chief executive
stroke head of paid services if that
becomes necessary
for all other chief officer recruitment
the joint
appointments committee would appoint a
subcommittee comprising six members
again politically balanced and i would
just stress it has to be politically
balanced
uh drawn from the joint appointments
committee
so
we have
the six members are drawn from our
current appointments committee
the six members being proposed four from
the conservatives and two from the
liberal democrats
are myself
our councillors pemberton barker and
harvey
and from the liberal democrats
councillor ian fragili and councillor
olcock
so
with that and
there are
eight recommendations but the important
one is the first one
this is subject to warwick district
council resolving on the same terms in
relation to all the other
recommendations
so
i propose we accept the recommendations
and move forward with the joint
appointments committee with the names i
outlined earlier
thank you uh looks like uh secondary
counselor darren pemberton uh i'd like
to invite phil grafton to comment
um it's only just to say that obviously
myself um david buckland and tony perks
all have a an interest in this because
we might be subject to those
appointments um at some stage but i
don't think that affects our ability to
stay in the room and advise you as
necessary and i would just add that the
hr policy which is part of or was part
of the report that went to the committee
the other night has been devised solely
by the hr team thank you thank you any
further comments is everyone in
agreement
lovely so item 16 minute 575
uh sorry councillor harris just before
you move on we never clarified on the
last point does three of us disagree
with what the conclusion was we were
conflating a few issues we weren't
talking about what council harvey meant
about one meeting in six months we were
talking about the eight meetings in a
year and the punitive way that councils
can have their allowance withhold we
just wanted clarity for council that
that will be discussed again in future
thank you that's noted
so um item 16 the pay policy statement
please invite council jefferson to
introduce this report
thank you chair
um
believe it or not the localism act of
2011 requires the council to publish
information relating to pay for senior
management managers by producing a pay
policy statement
so the pay policy statement went to
employment and appointments committee on
the 17th of february
there are a lot of specific matters
which must be included in the council's
statutory pay policy
uh there is indeed a long list in the
paper
uh the payer policy statement 2223
includes all of the requirements it
needs to contain
and it reflects a new management
structure which was attached as appendix
one to the paper
given that this is something that is
routine and the debate
at the employment and appointments
committee did not last terribly long so
i recommend the pay policy statement
be adopted for the period 2223
thank you and i'll look for a seconder
councillor pemberton
i'm going to hand over to phil grafton
to comment
i'm sorry about this but i think
it's right that the three of us declare
an interest in this because obviously
the pay policy affects myself david
buckland and tony pertz but there again
i don't feel we need to leave the room
um we can advise you as necessary as
there's nothing directly connected with
ourselves at the moment thank you thank
you any further comments
notice everyone in agreement
lovely item 17 taiso neighborhood
development plan um
um i'd not like to invite council
permanent to introduce this report thank
you chairman um
members taiso's neighborhood development
plan uh went to its referendum on the
20th of january um the plan was endorsed
by the community it was a 92.2 yes votes
uh on a ballot that generated a forty
six percent turnout which is actually
quite high in terms of ndps um in
recommending to council that the tyson
neighborhood
with the consequence that it becomes
part of the development plan for
stratford on avon district i'd like to
thank um tyso's uh parish council
tarsa's neighborhood development plan
group and i'd like to particularly
record in the minutes a specific vote of
thanks
to matthew neal who has lived and
breathed this particular end of ndp for
uh what seems to be quite some time but
it has been one that has required some
um some intricate work uh with the ndp
group with uh the uh examining inspector
uh and um to coin a phrase that's uh
that's used in the planning policy team
he played a blinder so i would like that
recorded in the minutes uh specifically
for matthew neal's work on that
particular piece of work and with that i
uh commend and recommend to council the
adoption of the taito neighborhood
development plan thank you thank you and
i'll seek for a second council fielding
thank you
and would you like to comment
well i'd like to thank the hard work of
the parish council and
the neighborhood development plan
there's been some very interesting and
lively debates at the parish council
over this
which um
was an eye-opener when i first joined
the dis the district council
but um and also the officers
um
and matthew neil etc and uh
i'm glad it's gone through thank you
very much
thank you any further comments
uh phil grafton
i don't want to make a habit of this but
i've got to declare an interest in this
because i live in the parish
thank you
yeah
are there any further comments from
councillors council fielding we haven't
seen him there no
great so all agreed
thank you uh item 18 there's nothing to
report for outside business so
accounts junit
i looked through the list of outside
annual update from outside bodies uh and
against cells to high um heritage trust
there was nothing uh can i announce that
we were successful in getting a bid from
the museum's uh west midlands museum
development service and you are welcome
to come to
uh ulster for our roman celebration on
june the 11th which will be followed on
june the 12th by a roman theme to street
market we would love to see you there
thank you and congratulations
um item 19 uh urgent reports um just for
noting and we've considered item six and
agenda so it's just the loan to spring
housing association the fred winter
center okay so moving on to item 20 the
counselor questions so 11 questions have
been received and these have been
circulated to everyone
on a separate sheet so all members
asking questions we'll have the
opportunity to ask one supplementary
question
and i'll go first please to counselor
shenzhen just what's the time frame
around it with um the uh what you stated
thank you for the question uh counselor
um
i can't give you a definitive answer on
that just at the moment but i'll come
back to you fine thank you um counselor
together
um thank you um councilor par is not
here but um with a greater respect
can i suggest that this answer is not
helpful at all for a residence surely
dropped kerbs for pedestrians especially
those with mobility issues should be
conditioned by stratfor district council
in consultation with the statutory
authority
county highway in this case at the time
of granting planning permission in view
of the equality act
thank you
um
would you like to comment tony
i just wanted to say in the absence of
council parry i will take that away
for council barry to answer
thank you
uh councillor ian bradley do you have a
supplementary question
uh sancoche
not at this moment i i welcome the uh
prep
preparation of policy guidelines
and the fact that it's going out to
consultation
uh and maybe we'll have some more
questions when we've seen the results of
that
thank you councillor jenny gradually
i'd just like to say thank you for the
very the very comprehensive answer i
think there'll be some follow-on from
this and we do need to keep this on our
agenda particularly with uh listed
houses
thank you councillor barker
since this answer was written counselor
frankly um
i've had a few people in contact with me
particularly about listed houses
um and it's a very very live issue um
we've got i've i've got quite a lot of
information coming in about it and we
certainly are going to pursue it it's
something i've i've had raised with me
by
architects and builders who are my
acquaintances as well so it really needs
sorting well done for race again thank
you
thank you i know councilor curtis is
absent so moving on to the councillor
walcott
thank you mr
thank you chair um
yes i suppose this could be the answer
of how long the piece of string but how
long are residents gonna have to wait
to see if the west midlands combined
authority want to take on windsor street
car park in stratford-upon-avon before
work is done on it it is in a state
um
and residents are being kept waiting
first for one project and for possibly
for another
um
and so you know is there a plan if the
west middle authority don't come forward
and say we will have it we will sort it
out does this council have a plan for
winter street car park in
stratford-upon-avon town
thank you council jefferson
the answer is that at the moment the
windsor street car park is considered as
a part of the gateway project as a whole
and should anything change then we will
need to put in place a plan have we got
one at the moment specifically about
windsor street car park the answer is no
thank you councillor rock do you have a
supplementary question yes thank you
chairman i thank councillor parker for a
very clear concise and direct answer
and
would you agree with me that um the
government's rather repeat offenders
in this case of standing up one day
making an announcement which others have
got to implement
and i certainly thank our officers for
the hard work in doing this but they're
very good at not working out how these
things are going to be done and dumping
on local authorities
and once more it's very disappointing
that central government
handles the red cross passes those have
been interested in rugby football we all
know and we've suddenly got to pick up
the ball and run with it and it's uh
it's very unfortunate would you agree
with me that there's some room for
improvement in how central government uh
deals with that thank you chairman
um yeah i i would absolutely agree there
is room for improvement but i don't know
um how we're going to do that we've had
so many of these schemes i will just say
that uh at lunch time today i went in to
see mr platz who was on a webinar about
this very issue um there still wasn't a
conclusion because there are some
complexities to it that nobody had
thought of
there's a common theme and um
it will be it will be finalized and the
one thing i would say that in this
authority we will not drag our heels
once we know how to do it
we will get it in motion really really
quickly and if the guys and girls have
to work over a weekend implementing it
which they've done before
they'll do it
again
thank you councillor mills do you have a
supplementary question
yes i do mr chairman i mean
thank you um
a lot has been said about
mentioning
council shenton today
and um
i have to commend him on
it we had a a fire the pure recycling
plant had that extremely well and of
course we also had the the bitter fire
um of the biffa lori and i'm
i have to applaud councillor shenton for
uh
you know making investigations this
inquiry that went on for quite some time
and it turns out that um through the
investigation
the
batteries which which caused the fire um
were pushed into the normal waste bin
and it turns out that the
the batteries landed on
could have been a pork chop or whatever
but it was a salts
from the from the meats that landed on
the batteries
that caused the fire and i'm ashamed to
say that it's someone in for me my award
who did that he's been charged
and he's been charged with assault on
battery
council would you like to respond
thank you thank you chairman i don't
think i can beat that
counselor do you have any supplementary
questions no thank you chair
thank
you council richards is absent uh cancer
fieldings you have a supplementary
question
yes thank you chairman
um
two of the
seven pubs in my award are taking
advantage of this scheme
how many others are looking how many
other businesses are looking at this
scheme and asking for grant support
council jefferson
to be quite honest uh council feeling i
can't answer that at the moment i will
try and find out the numbers and get
back to you
but what i would say is you can see from
the immediate response the number of
businesses we have supported across the
district
are very very significant very
substantial and it has made a real
difference to businesses in the district
thank you so moving on to item 21
questions to the leader
each member has two questions um three
minutes
uh for each council please and only
matters that are the responsibility
of this council any uh councillor rock
thank you chairman
uh the leader will recollect that he
gave a response to my question at the
october council meeting
regarding the detention of nazanin's
azari radcliffe where he undertook to
write to the foreign secretary and to
our local mps
i thank him for that response and indeed
to support the whole council that was
expressed towards me and the family who
live in my ward
during last week bbc radio 4 ran a
documentary about the detention of mrs
radcliffe which is well worth listening
to on catch-up
did the leader receive a response to the
approach he made
both from the government and from the
mps
and would i be able to share that with
the family please
thank you council iraq
i can unfortunately confirm that i
received no response from the foreign
secretary so unfortunately i can't share
it
thank you councillor junaid
um does could the leader
agree
with sir john major's recently expressed
views on the current state of politics
at westminster
i cannot
recollect sir john mage's comments could
you refresh my mind please counseling
and i think okay i think leader it was
mainly to do with
what is actually underwriting the
current mistrust in politics and
thrashing of democracy crashing of the
values that underpin our democracy or
something aligned to that
not sure this is really an issue for the
leader of the district council but
if i'm really honest my view would be
that politics in the uk has been on a
downhill slide for a long long time
uh i think it is very unfortunate that
that has happened
uh i think
if i am being brutally honest an awful
lot of it is down to the caliber of
people that are selected to become
members of parliament
i think we are facing a particular set
of problems now
in a world that is growing increasingly
complex and increasingly fraught
um
i think it is going to be an interesting
challenge for all politicians in
westminster
to get their act together to actually
deal with what is going to be
an unbelievably challenging situation
for many of our citizens
i think one of the things that is very
clear
about this year is we are all going to
be poorer
and that will pose a significant
challenge because it's not somewhere
we've been for a long time
so given the uncertainty given the
fraughtness of the situation
i can only hope that the caliber of
politics and politicians improve
somewhat
thank you council adam
thank you very much um last week i had
the opportunity to
visit the
hs2 development site my um my award
unfortunately i wasn't able to go down
into the uh the tunnel as as we had been
um
uh offered in initially um and as a
result it was just myself going to the
uh the visitors center uh the promise
was though that i would be invited back
with the neighboring ward members to
uh see more um detailed information
about the the development and actually
visit the the tunnel boring machine
itself
as this is such a major impact on the
district and the landscape i was
wondering if you might be interested in
um joining us on that expedition when it
was
um proposed to us by hs2 so that you
could see for yourself what's going on
in the district in in our area thank you
i would be absolutely fascinated to
visit the tunnel in the tunneling
machine tunneling machine in particular
because as i understand it
these tunneling machines are
specifically designed
for developing that tunnel so yes i
would be absolutely fascinated subject
to my diary i would love to do it
you know i'd like to go start as well
that sounds pretty good
uh counselor tyra coach counselor yeah a
counselor ian presley
thank you chair
uh in december this council announced
that there would be a study to look at
making the long marston airfield
development
more self-contained reducing the need
for travel and looking at greener
transport solutions
would the leader please tell me whether
the timetable for this study is
available and if not when it will become
available
thank you
i have just been informed that it's you
for publishing in june
counselor fielding
thank you chair
does the
leader agree with me
that
i abstained at the
vote on climate
change or climate emergency i don't
think it's an emergency
that we are
now suddenly finding coming to roost a
lot of the
problems
that are
coming forward from the government and
we are not in a position yet to cope
with them for instance some of the
poorer rural houses
are having to do away with
or will not be able to buy after 24 25
oil fired boilers
so they've got to do gas or go into
um heat source pumps but the cost of
heat source pumps is around 20 000
a lot of these people won't be afraid is
there anything that can be done to
help these people or
looking forward with regards to planning
matters particularly we were talking
about
um
listed buildings these are something i'd
like
coming up thank you thank you councillor
failing
a very interesting question
i think there have been an awful lot of
policy pronouncements on climate change
i
do not think at the moment that the
implications of an awful lot of the
to work on the ground has been thought
through
and i think the reality is actually
going to be
when you start to look at the
practical consequences of implementing
some of these policies
i suspect there will be the need to
revisit and review
particularly in terms of the time scales
however
there is a real challenge
because
um
emissions have to be tackled rapidly so
how one actually squares that
with the need to ensure that the
policies and the implementation of those
policies are practical and doable
is going to be a real challenge
and at the moment
people are putting both of these
together
to put to
create
a way through
that actually delivers what we want in
terms of
cutting emissions and yet enabling
people to actually do what needs to be
done to do that
in a practical and pragmatic and
cost-effective way
thank you councillor bromwich
yeah leader earlier on when we were
debating our budget
i mentioned possibly the need that
people from
all parties and independents that should
be
looking to get their heads together to
find out ways that we can actually
improve the businesses and diversify our
economy within this district
you may recall when we had the cove to
action recovery group we had a good
variation of councils on there and
discussed a lot about the economic
recovery
i do think it's time now we need a
summer makeup of a committee to look at
how we diversify our local economy
how we
look to improve
ways for the council to have a
revenue
i think what we have not
had for a long time
for various reasons
is a way forward to get a proper
consensus on how we can take this
forward we've all done steve had good
ideas from the lib dems we've had good
ideas put forth from many members in
this council over the past 12 months
but i think we now need to be looking at
more coordination and try it and realize
that we probably did put our eggs too
much in one basket in tourism over the
years
and we probably need to find better ways
to diversify and i think this has to be
done for our consensus across all
groupings within this council
and i think certainly something like
where we have the coverage recovery
group maybe we need an economic
diversity group
thank you councillor bromwich
interesting
uh
the main industry in our district is
actually not tourism it's manufacturing
which
is comes as a surprise to many people
in terms of diversifying the economy
there is an awful lot of work going on
at the moment looking
at the economy and stratfor district
uh i mentioned in my leaders
announcements
uh
that
i went to a meeting with vice chancellor
of the university of warwick
and the director in charge of the
wellsborne campus
and the leader of warwick district
the wellsborne campus is an innovation
campus
it will be
i think quite genuinely of international
significance
it will diversify our economy
very very substantially
the
jobs it will create
are all high-end jobs
at the moment the focus is largely on
electric vehicles and agri-tech
based on the original
i think it was
agriculture research center that was
there
right next door
to
the wells barn campus is wellsborne
airfield
we are working very hard
to deliver
uh
schemes for wellsborne airfield that
will enable the businesses that do the
innovation and research and development
on the campus
to set up their manufacturing
units
on that site
that is
those two put together are a staggering
opportunity for this district
for the region
and even for the country it's that kind
of scale of ambition
i mentioned again
uh in my
leaders announcements that we'd had
discussions with lotus
that was the context of the discussions
with lotus lotus incidentally now
at wellspawn
they are going up to 300 jobs
these are all high-end engineering jobs
that's where their consultancy armies
and it's where they are developing all
the
electric drive trains and electric power
for their future generations of cars
we also have in the district at long
marston
brook rail innovation center
uh
that's where the very light
rail concept was developed
we've yet to visit porter brook to find
out what's going on there but that is
another potential source
of diversity of jobs
the difficulty with an awful lot of this
is it takes
a lot of behind the scenes activity
and a long time to bring these things
about
i mean we've been working on the wells
born airfield now for probably
four years
you know it's it takes this length of
time but we have invested the time we've
invested the effort
we've invested if you like this
strategic vision to bring it about
uh
i think in all fairness
partially because of the timing in
trying to bring these things about
we haven't been able to keep counsellors
fully up to speed and you will
appreciate that a lot of the
discussions are commercially
confidential
all i will say is i am in full agreement
with you councillor bromwich
we really do need to diversify the
economy as much as we can
we are working on it
if i am really honest i think that at
the moment we are laying the foundations
to ensure
the long-term prosperity of this
district
and the interesting thing is that
when i talk to people in the west
midlands combined authority
it is only just now
they are beginning to realize exactly
what our district has to offer
and it is substantial
if you look at the west midlands as a
whole
the growth in the west midlands is
solihull coventry warwick and ourselves
and there is one huge advantage we have
as a district
we are 48 of warwickshire by area
we have land and one of the main
constraints at the moment across the
west midlands is
a lack of land for industrial and
commercial development
and people are now beginning to realize
just how significant
i think we'll take your ideas away about
getting cancers together and see what we
can do
but i have to say given the work that
we're putting in at the moment
and given the opportunities around
i am hugely optimistic
about the future of the district
thank you councillor forschuk
thank you chair uh yeah with the um
improvements on phase one of um
henley street
obviously overseas visitors
have an improved visitor experience as
well as domestic visitors and locals as
well
um
will the leader be
trying everything he can
to
find funding to finish the job
thank you council of phoenix yes
thanks councillor pertiguella
hey um
you might be aware that some residents
in new developments are fighting to have
ill-fitted windows and doors replaced
and are tackling other serious issues in
their newly built homes
does the leader agree with me that
houses must be built to high quality
standards and what can the district
council do as the planning authority to
improve house builder standards when
they build in our district
would agree that houses should be built
to high standards
uh i think what you're talking about
counselor pertoguella is not about the
design
it's actually about the construction
and i'm not exactly sure what we can do
about
construction quality
council wally hoggins
yeah it's just a point of clarity really
from an earlier conv earlier point made
by councillor fielding i would like to
say to uh that my husband is the
managing director of red horse fuel so
it's a fuel company but i would like to
say this that the oil boilers are
proposed to be phased out by 2025 for
new build properties only
not for properties that currently have
oil oil boilers that you'll still be
able to replace that boiler in that
house should it should it break down i
would actually encourage people to do
that because you will actually get a
much lower rate of oil could i also say
that off tech is working incredibly hard
with the oil and still
oil installers and
fuel deliveries on finding ways in which
we can actually clean up
oil consumption there's there's lots and
lots of technology coming down the line
so uh council jefferson if you could
encourage the manufacturing people
around here to scratch their heads and
come up with that
because there is a way that they're
going to be able to change the um
currently there's going to be a way
they're going to be able to change the
newer oil boilers to taking hvo fuels
for those of you unaware of us if you
like that's a biodiesel
but currently biodiesel for central
heating is phenomenally expensive um it
far out strips anything i do have to say
though that the electricity prices at
the moment will be sharpening pro
sharpening people's minds with regard to
all of their sort of heat source pumps
and air source heat pumps so i hope
that's added some clarity and that
nobody stopped me from speaking so thank
you but it is important because this is
a big industry and a lot of people
particularly in our rural patches are
relying on on oil fuel we mustn't use
scare tactics with them thank you
comes thank you councillor willie
hoggins uh for that clarification
and um
i now know more about the subject than i
did before
thank you councillor fielding your
second question my second question thank
you chairman
um on bbc news this morning they were
talking to a farmer in south
warwickshire
about the suicide
rate and the depression that's within
the farming community
is the district council working with the
nfu or other bodies to
make sure that the well-being side of
the district council is working closely
with them
the frankly council feeling i'm not sure
but i'll find out and let you know
council brothers your second question
we've obviously talked a lot today about
finances people's cost of living and
tightening budgets
i think one thing that's come to me in
mind over the past few weeks from
residents that have approached me is
someone very fearful about what we have
voted for today which is council tax
increases
and trying to we've had to try they're
above the councils but we've had to try
and explain
why we have to increase this sort of
thing
there will be residents that will
struggle even
with statutory help
and lead what i'm asking for now is
can we try and make awareness that the
district council will help these people
if they are struggling money with money
financially whether it's with council
tax rent
experience what we have done as a
council we have done very well but i
think we as councils ourselves have a
moral duty to help our residents on this
and i think the council probably putting
a bit more awareness in the public eye
saying don't
put the problem off if you're struggling
come and talk to us i think would be
very much appreciated especially if it's
in some performance press release
thank you councillor bromage i think we
will take your suggestions on board very
sensible very pragmatic
thank you everyone are there any further
questions
no okay so moving on to item 22 we have
a motion notice so
uh just to clarify that the motion once
proposed and seconded will be referred
to the cabinet for consideration and uh
reports without debate so please now
call upon councillors edin and junior to
propose and second the following notice
of motion
thank you chair um
i won't speak on it very much but this
is a great chance to fix a number of
problems for
the climate change emergency and uh
costs possibly of things like
maintenance of verges
um
so i gladly propose this motion
thank you counselor and i'm happy to
second it
thank you
so item 23 um we've got uh information
only that the tree planting motion um is
being deferred pending report from
officers and also the competitive bids
and grants motion has also been deferred
pending report from officers
um is there any urgent business
no
um so the next meeting is on monday the
25th of april uh at two o'clock and i'd
like to close this meeting thank you
everyone